EDUCATION TO ORDER AND- NOT
HAVING A QUORUM WILL BEGIN AS A
SUB COMMITTEE AND TELLER AND SO
WE HAVE A QUORUM. SO WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION'S BILL HEARING.
WHETHER YOU ARE HERE IN PERSON
OR WATCHING VIRTUALLY ON THE
PHONE LINES I AM GRATEFUL YOU
HAVE JOINED IS. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IS SOMEBODY MEMBER MIKE FONG HAS
BEEN APPOINTED TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOAQUIN ARAMBULA
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. I WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE FONG. FOR
WHAT MAY BE YOUR FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE HEARING SINCE BECOMING
A STATE LEGISLATOR. GLAD TO HAVE
YOU WITH US TODAY. AT
ADDITIONALLY PLEASE NOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC BLOOM WILL
BE ABSENT FROM TODAY'S HEARING.
I WILL NOT GO OVER SOME OF THE
KEY ELEMENTS OF THE STRUCTURE OF
TODAY'S HEARING. WHILE IT'S
FINALLY LOOKING LIKE WE'RE
BEGINNING TO HAVE A SEMBLANCE OF
NORMALCY WE ARE NOT STILL 1100%
BACK TO PRE PANDEMIC TIMES. SO
DUE TO THE ONGOING PANDEMIC
WE'RE STILL PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE C. IN THIS HEARING AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAP. WE WERE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE PHYSICALLY PRESENT TO
OBSERVE AND PARTICIPATE DURING
THIS HEARING. IF YOU'RE HERE IN
PERSON PLEASE NOTE. THAT WHILE
MASS ARE NO LONGER REQUIRED THEY
ARE RECOMMENDED REGARDLESS OF
VACCINE STATUS. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
WEAR A MASK AND DON'T HAVE ONE
PLEASE NOTE THAT MASK ARE
AVAILABLE FREE OF CHARGE OF THE
SECURITY CHECKPOINTS OF THE
ENTRANCE OF THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE HAVE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY IN PERSON AND VIA THE
PHONE LINES. IN PERSON
INSTRUCTIONS IF ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC OR IN THE ROOM WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THE PUBLIC NOT TO TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARINGS WENT TO FINISH
TESTIFYING OR YOU CAN RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON
THE ELEVATOR TO THE INDICATED
NUMBER ON THE SIGN POSTED BY THE
ELEVATOR DOORS. WE WILL ALSO BE
USING THE A. T. AND T. MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND
EXPRESS THEIR POSITION ON THE
BILL. THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT
DELAY SO AGAIN I ASK THAT YOU
REMAIN PATIENT. THE PUBLIC TOLL
FREE NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING. IS
ONE EIGHT SAID EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN.
CAN ALSO FIND THE NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV OR MONITOR SCREEN. IF
YOU ARE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL YOU'RE TESTIFYING. ON IS
BEGINNING THEY'RE BUILT
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT R OPPOSE THE BILL.
IF YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVE
STREAM BROADCASTS AND YOUR SMART
DEVICE. TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION.PLEASE BE SURE TO
MUTE YOUR PHONE WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING. DO YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE PLEASE CALL THE
COMMITTEE OFFICE AT. NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE
SIX SO. AND COMMITTEE STAFF WILL
DO THEIR BEST TO ASSIST YOU.
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. ADDITIONALLY PLEASE
NOTE THAT THE GUIDELINE FOR
BILLS HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE IS
TO ALLOW TESTIMONY FROM TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK FOR NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES EACH. STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
AND ENTITIES THAT ARE NEITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
ALLOWED TO GVE TESTIMONY FOR NO
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES WHEN I
CALLED FOR TWEETERS. THE MEASURE
AS MORE THAN TWO ENTITIES IN THE
TWEENER KALACH CATEGORY ONLY TWO
WILL BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
WHILE ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC. HEALTH
CONCERNS THAT WE ALSO FACE. FOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF YOU WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO
A ROLL CALL ASK A QUESTION OR
PROVIDE A COMMENT- ASKS THAT YOU
RAISE YOUR HAND AND ACTIVATE
YOUR VOLUME BUTTON. ON YOUR DÍAS
MICROPHONE. EACH MEMBER
PRESENTING THIS IS FOR AUTHORS
EACH MEMBER PRESENTING TODAY
WILL PROVIDE AN OPENING AND
pAS PREVIOUSLY STATED YOUR LEAD
WITNESS WILL EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY. WE
HAVE SEVEN MEASURES ON THE
AGENDA TODAY FIVE TO BE
PRESENTED AND TWO ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MEASURES WILL BE TAKEN
UP AND FILE ORDER HOWEVER I WILL
PRESENT LAST. MEASURES ON THE
AGENDA R. A. B. SIXTEEN OH TWO
AB SEVENTEEN OH ONE A. B.
SEVENTEEN TWELVE. AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SIX AND H. R. RESOLUTION
EIGHTY SIX MEASURES ON CONSENT
OUR AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE AND
A. B. NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. WITH
THE COR NOPE NOPE OKAY. ALL
RIGHT SO WE WILL CONTINUE AS A
SUB COMMITTEE AND WE WILL GO TO
THE FIRST ITEM A. B. SIXTEEN OH
TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
WELCOME. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
GOOD TO BE HERE AT THE FIRST
HEARING OF THE YEAR CORRECT
CORRECT IN THE FIRST BILL THE
YEAR. AND THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW WE HAD A BIG DEBATE
YESTERDAY. IN THE ASSEMBLY ABOUT
UC BERKELEY. AND ENROLLMENT AND
SYKORA ALL THOSE OTHER STUFF
HAPPENING BUT THE UNDERLYING
ISSUE THERE. WAS IS ON DEATH
HOUSING FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS AT
OUR AMPUSES. THIS DEALS WITH
THE STUDENTS TODAY THAT ARE
FACING HOUSING INSECURITY AND
SOME FRANKLY ARE HOMELESS. AT
THIS DEALS WITH OUR QUEST THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON TO BUILD MORE-
TO EXPAND ENROLLMENT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AT OUR UC SYSTEM OR
CSU SYSTEM WE NEED MORE HOUSING
ON CAMPUS SO. I'M PRESENTING YOU
TODAY AB SIXTY NO TO AUTHORED BY
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER TANG AND
MYSELF. TO BRING UP AND SIT
MEMBER CERVANTES TO BRING ABOUT
MORE STUDENT HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA THIS WOULD CREATE A
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR CALIFORNIA
STUDENT HOUSING FUND. TO PROVIDE
ZERO INTEREST LOANS FOR UC CSU
INCOMMUNICADO LEDGES TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING
FOCUSES STUDENTS WE ARE
FLEXIBILITY FOR OTHER STAFF AT
THE SEGMENTS. AGAIN WE KNOW THAT
HOUSING IS A KEY CONTRIBUTOR TO
CALIFORNIA'S COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS IT ACCOUNTS
FOR ROUGHLY HALF OF THE TOTAL
COST OF GOING TO COLLEGE
HOUSING. AS A RESULT MORE MORE
COLLEGE STUDENTS FACE HOUSING
INSECURITY. WHICH NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS OUR ABILITY TO ATTEND.
CLLR AND PERFORM. BUT PROVIDING
FIVE BILLIONS INTEREST LOANS WE
ESTIMATE THIS COULD BUILD AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
BEDS IN CALIFORNIA TO DEAL WITH.
OUR CURRENT- CRISIS AS WELL AS-
FOCUSING ON ON FUTURE DEMAND.
BECAUSE THIS IS A REVOLVING LOAN
LOAN FUND IT WILL LEVERAGE ONE
TIME FUNDING TO PROVIDE AN ON
GOING FUNDING SOURCE FOR STUDENT
HOUSING ESSENTIALLY REPLENISHING
ITSELF. OVER TIME- THESE LOAN
REPAYMENTS WOULD BE RETURNED AND
FOUND OTHER. OBJECTS IN FINANCE
FUTURE HOUSING NEEDS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AT THIS WILL ALSO
HELP DEAL WITH CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS LET'S FACE IT
MANY AS COLLEGE CAMPUSES
STUDENTS ARE LIVING IN THE
OUTSKIRTS OF THE CAMPUS AND
THEY'RE TAKING AWAY HOUSING THAT
COULD BE USED FOR OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE COMMUNITY. THIS DEALS
WITH WITH TWO REALLY KEY ISSUES-
I AM CERTAINLY COMMITTED TO WORK
WITH ALL INTERESTED PARTIES I
KNOW THAT THERE IS AN INTEREST
IN MAKING SURE WE HAVE. AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE YOUR
THESE PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE NOT
ONLY PAYING PREVAILING WAGE BUT
I ALSO HAVE- LEGITIMATE. AND
PROFESSIONAL CONTRACTORS THAT
TAKE CARE OF THEIR WORKERS PAY
THEIR WORKERS LIVING WAGES AND
ALSO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TO BUILD
UP WORKERS. HAS NOT LOST UPON ME
THAT THIS WILL FOCUS ON STUDENTS
GOING TO COLLEGE WE ALSO SHOULD
FOCUS ON THE STUDENTS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH THAT. AND WE ARE
WORKING WITH OUR LABOR PARTNERS
AND LEADERSHIP IN THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE DISTRACTED BALLOTS
YEARS WORKING ON THAT AS THIS
BILL. MOVES ALONG THAT WITH ME
TODAY IS THE CHANCELLOR FROM UC
SAN DIEGO CHANCELLOR KHOSLA AS
WELL AS A STUDENT REPRESENTING
THE STUDENT VOICE THANK YOU. I
GET. I'M GONNA TAKE A SMALL
BREAK HERE- TO HAVE THE AS
SECRETARY. I'LL FOR THE-
PRETENDS MEDINA HERE CHOI YEAH
FONG BLOOM GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY
LEVINE LOW. SANTIAGO VALLADARES
WEBER. BEFORE QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED- WE LIKE TO CALL
YOUR ON YOUR FIRST WITNESS YES
THANK YOU MISTER BECAUSE LA. BUT
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY GOOD MORNING GERMANY NOW
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR THE USE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO FIND OUR MUCH
NEEDED HOUSING COURSE WHO. I'M
PLEASED TO SHARE THAT INVOLVED
TWENTY TWENTY UC SAN DIEGO OPEN
THE FOR LIVING AND LEARNING
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA CALLED
THENORTH KOREAN CLIENTS LIVING
AND LEARNING NEIGHBORHOOD. THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD IS THE TWO THOUSAND
BUT FACILITY FOR A FIX COLLEGE.
WE ALSO HAVE UNDER CONSTRUCTION
THE THEATER DISTRICT LIVING
LEARNING NEIGHBORHOODS WHICH IS
ANOTHER TWO THOUSAND BED.
FACILITY AND WILL OPEN IN FALL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. EVEN THOUGH
WE HAVE UILT A LOT WE ARE
ANXIOUS TO BUILD MORE BECAUSE
OUR GOAL IS TO OFFER FOR YOU
HOUSING GUARANTEED TO OUR
UNDERGRADS. AT BELOW MARKET
RATES. RECENTLY WE WILL RECORD
BUT WE WERE PLEASANTLY. WHEN TWO
WEEKS AGO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE RECOMMENDED THE
LEGISLATURE FUND HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS TOWARDS UC SAN DIEGO
SEVERAL CANYON LET'S HOUSING
PROJECT. WITH THE NEW GRANT
FUNDING FOR SOME HOUSING LET AT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
LAST YEAR. EVER CANYON WESSEL
HOUSE UPPER DIVISION AND
TRANSFER STUDENTS. NEXT TO A NEW
LIGHT PROBABLY STOP CAMPUS. AND
IT WILL PROVE THIS FUNDING WOULD
ALLOW US TO BUILD A THIRTY
HUNDRED BAD. AND ALSO PROVIDE
IT'LL HUNDRED OKAY. NEEDIEST
TUNES AROUND DISCOUNT OF UP. 50%
BELOW MARKET. THIS IS VERY. WELL
THE UC SANTA CA REALLY GREAT
DEPRESSION ABOUT THE LATEST WORK
TO CREATE A FROM BUT SOMEHOW WE
BELIEVE THAT A GROUP WALDRON
WITH ZERO PER AND RATE WILL
ALLOW THE CARE. THE BILL EVEN
MORE HOW ON CAMP MACRON FOR RUNS
FOR AND HELP PRESERVE THAT
CAPACITY FOR OTHER CORE MISSION
CAPITAL PROJECTS AS O- THE
PUBLIC NOT REQUIRE SAID THIS
WILL BE A REVOLVING LINE OF LOAN
THAT WILL KEEP ON BUILDING
HOUSING FOR A VERY LONG TIME TO
COME. SO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU HAVE
THAT LET THEM ATTEND THE IMPACT
OF THE EVERY HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT UC SAN DIEGO THIS
WEEK AND SEE PERCENT AND BECAUSE
AS PART OF THIS BOOK- IN LONG
WOULD GENERATE AND IN ORDER
SAVINGS OF TWO ONE. WHICH COULD
BE DOES FOR THE LOOK AT
THOUSANDS TO- OF ABOUT MEDIA
ONES AND BEES WILL BECOME
RESIDENTS AND THIS WOULD NOT
REALLY CONSTRUCT THAT BUT IT
WOULD ALLOW TO INVEST TO ONE
DOLLARS. AND MAPPING TO THE
STATE FIVE MILLION DOLLAR IN
HOUSE EIGHT TO BECAUSE RESIDENTS
TO ORDER THIRTY FOR YEAR
PREPAYMENT PERIOD OF LONG SO FOR
EVERY HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THIRTY FIVE WILL END UP
GETTING SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
A HOUSING EIGHT AND ONE THAT THE
SECTOR INTO THE RIGHT. IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN GOOD THIRTY OF THE 8%
BRENT BELOW THIRTY IF BELOW RATE
FOR UNDERGRADUATES ON A VERY
SIGNIFICANT BELOW MARK THE OKAY. THIS ALSO CREATE A ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY CLICK ON. JOB OR THREE
YEAR PERIOD. AND ABOUT THIRTY
NINE. BECAUSE CODY AND BY THAT I
PROGRAM JOBS. AND IF THE STATE
ALLOW US TO MEDIC THE GROUP
FIVE. THE FUNDS COULD BE THE
LEAD. AS THE FEDERAL MCCARTY
SAID. THE BILL AND IT'S NOT BAD
FOR FUNDING. HOUSING A.
XPANDER INVENTORY FROM ABOUT
TWELVE THOUSAND BEDS IN
201-321-8000 BUT TODAY WHICH IS
A NET INCREASE OF SIX THOUSAND
BUT TO OFFER OFFER A FORTY
HOUSING GUARANTEE WE NEED TO ADD
ABOUT TEN TO TWELVE THOUSAND
BEDS MORE OVER THE NEXT SEVEN TO
TEN YEARS. THIS LOAN THAT YOU
ABOUT TO CONSIDER VEHICLE OFF
WOULD BE VERY SIGNIFICANT IN THE
UC SAN DIEGO'S ABILITY TO OFFER
A FORTY HOUSING GUARANTEE. THEN
I CAN PRETTY MUCH GUARANTEE YOU
IT WILL HELP OTHER CAMPUSES IN
THE UC IN THE SAME WAY. THAT IT
WOULD HELP UC SAN DIEGO. SO LET
ME JUST FINISH BY SAYING THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT A REVOLVING LOAN
INTEREST RATES AT 0% WOULD
EXPONENTIALLY INCREASE THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT IN FROM
HOUSING. IT IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO. UC CAMPUSES WOULD BENEFIT
GREATLY AND BE ABLE TO BUILD
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE HOUSING THAT
ONE TIME FUNDING TO PROVIDE. I
CANNOT SUPPORT THIS ANYMORE
STRONGLY THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE
A SECOND WITNESS WAS MCCARTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. PERFECT I GET AFTERNOON
CAMBODIA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GOING TO BE
COMING SHOKER AND I AM A
SOPHOMORE AT UC SAN DIEGO TODAY
I AM SPEAKING TO YOU ON BEHALF
OF GENERATION UP A STUDENT LED
ADVOCACY GROUP FOR EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY AND THE PRODUCT MONSTER
OF EIGHTY SIX YOU KNOW TO. AS
YOU ARE MOST LIKELY AWARE UCSB
AND COLLEGES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ARE EXPERIENCING A HOUSING
CRISIS. MORE THAN A THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE
OR ARE EXPERIENCING HOUSING
INSECURITY. AND IS ONE OF THOSE
COLLEGE STUDENTS LET ME TELL YOU
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE. FOR THE
LAST FEW YEARS I HAVE ACTUALLY
BEEN FORTUNATE FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO LIVE AT THE BEAUTIFUL NORTH
TORREY PINES LIVING AND LEARNING
COMMUNITY. AT CHAMPASAK WILL
MENTION I'M ACTUALLY SITTING IN
MY DORM ROOM RIGHT NOW. BUT NEXT
YEAR MY HOUSING GUARANTEE
EXPIRES AND I WILL HAVE TO SHARE
AN APARTMENT OFF CAMPUS BEFORE
OTHERS JUST MAKE GRANT. AND FOR
WORKING THREE JOBS AS A FULL
TIME STUDENT. IT MEANS THE
NINETY MINUTE DAILY COMMUTE FROM
RIVERSIDE. IT MEANS BEING FORCED
TO TAKE TIME OFF TRANSPORT OR
EVEN DROP OUT OF UC SAN DIEGO
BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY COULD NOT
FIND A PLACE TO LIVE. THESE ARE
NOT ISOLATED INCIDENTS EVERY
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENT HAVE
A HOUSING STORY OR KNOW SOMEONE
WHO DOES. AND NOTWITHSTANDING
THE ACADEMIC RIGOR OF CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSITIES COVERED NINETEEN
HAVE PLACED ADDITIONAL CHAPTERS
ON CURRENT COLLEGE STUDENT.
FINANCIAL STRAIN FAMILY CARE
GIVING RESPONSIBILITIES AND
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS. ON TOP OF THIS THE
TOLL THAT HOUSING INSECURITY
TAKES ON STUDENT BEING MENTAL
HEALTH AND ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED. IN ORDER
TO LEARN AND THRIVE YOU NEED TO
HAVE THEIR BASIC NEEDS MET
INCLUDING ACCESS TO AN
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE. IN
CALIFORNIA WE AT THE STATE
COMMITTED TO MAKING HIGHER
EDUCATION MORE ACCESSIBLE AND
EQUITABLE THAN EVER BEFORE AND
SUPPORTING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS THE
NEXT STEP TOWARDS THAT GOAL. AB
SIXTEEN OH TWO WILL POSITIVELY
IMPACT THE LIVES OF STUDENTS BY
ESTABLISHING A FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR FUND TO HELP CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
BILLS MORE AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING. SO ON BEHALF OF
GENERATION UP AND THE STUDENT
VOICES WE REPRESENTS I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE THOSE ON.
EIGHTY SIXTEEN OKAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE HEARING ROOM.
THERE ARE PLEASE COME ON UP. BUT
THERE'S MORE SUPPORT. RIGHT THE
FUNDS WELL WE SAID AT THE
BEGINNING THAT THERE'D BE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. RIGHT OKAY
SO- OKAY YEAH LET ME LET ME GO.
TO AND ONE HUNDRED FIFTY PUBLIC
SUPPORT FOR OKAY ALL RIGHT- ANY
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WHEN IT COME UP TO THE MIKE AND-
GIVE THIS YEAR YOUR NAME. WHO
YOU'RE REPRESENTING. OR OKAY.
HELLO OKAY HI MY NAME'S JOHNSON
PRASAD I'M THE VICE PRESIDENT
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIVE AND WE ARE IN HIGH
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY NOT
SEEN ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM WILL WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OF ANY WITNESSES AND IN
SUPPORT ON A GIVE US YOUR NAME.
AND YOU MIGHT BE REPRESENTING.
FOR A TIME BY MODERATOR REPORT.
FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN OUT TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AT THAT ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
IT'S ONE SEVEN ZERO AND FIRST WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE. IS YOUR NAME AND-
YOUR SUPPORT. MISTER KAREN
MEMBERS STILL THE AS THE LEAD TO
SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND AS WELL
AS NOTED EARLIER IF HE IS THE
ONLY PERSON WORKING IN A VIRTUAL
TRY OUR MODERATOR AND GO TO THE
NEXT PERSON PLEASE. JUST YOUR
NAME AND THE GROUP YOUR
REPRESENTING. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
FORTY ONE. THANK YOU CLOSE
BERGEN BEHALF OF JEWISH FREE
LOAN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE AT. ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
A WITH THE YOUNG ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
EMPLOYEES UNION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE AT
NINETY FIVE. JANE CAN- WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINUM. ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE.
KATHLEEN MANZINI REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. LINE.
SEVENTY NINE. ONE SEVENTY NINE-
MY COULD OPEN. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN. NINE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN YEAR MIKE IS UP IN.
LINE ONE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT.
HI MY NAME IS MARK GARCIA. I'M A
DIFFICULT WILL TAKE THE PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES AND WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION UNLESS THE MERIT
GREAT B. RIGHT NOW WE'RE TAKING
WE'RE TAKING SUPPORT RIGHT NOW
SO IF YOU. COME BACK IN JUST A
MINUTE. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THAT TIME OKAY. SO
WE'LL GO TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WOULD LIKE TO COME
UP TO THE TABLE. YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE WELCOME TO SIT AT THE
TABLE IF YOU'D LIKE. RIGHT THE
WHOLE WORLD IT IS IT IS WE'RE
GETTING BACK TO IT. AND ANY YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES AND I TAKE A
SECOND WITNESS FOR TWO MINUTES
IF YOU HAVE ONE OKAY. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON- COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY PEOPLE OF MY NAME IS
ERIN LEHANE AND I APPEAR BEFORE
YOU ON BEHALF OF THE NEARLY HALF
A MILLION HARD WORKING
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS THAT MAKE
UP THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SIXTEEN OH TWO AND LESS
ADEQUATELY AMENDED WITH WORK
FORCE PROTECTIONS. WE SUPPORT
THE PREMISE OF THIS BILL WE
SHOULD ALL BE WORKING TOGETHER
TO CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COLLEGE BOUND KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT WE SHOULD NOT BE
DOING SO AT THE EXPENSE OF BLUE
COLLAR KIDS. WE HAVE REPEATEDLY
APPROACH THE AUTHOR TO INCLUDE
IMPORTANT LABOR STANDARDS THAT
WOULD NOT ONLY PROTECT WORKERS
BUT ALSO CREATE. CORRESPONDING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
NON COLLEGE BOUND KIDS BUT YET
TO NO AVAIL. EVERY TIME A
LEGISLATOR MAKES DECISION TO
INCLUDE SKILLED AND TRAINED
LABOR LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THEY'RE DOING TWO VERY IMPORTANT
THINGS. FIRST IT ENSURES THAT
ALL WORKERS ON A JOB SITE ARE
TREATED AND PAID FAIRLY AND I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY AND IT SHORT
SHIFTING WAYS SHOULD NOT BE
WELCOME TO CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
SECONDLY THAT A PERCENTAGE OF
THE CONSTRUCTION WORKERS ON SITE
ARE FROM AN ACCREDITED
APPRENTICE PROGRAM. THIS IN TURN
CREATES ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
IN OUR STATE OF THE ART
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS WHERE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SEVENTY TWO
THOUSAND APPRENTICES TRAINING TO
BE THE NEXT GENERATION. OF
SKILLED TRADES PERSON. AN
APPRENTICESHIP AT THE BUILDING
TRADES IS ONE OF THE VERY FEW
PASS TO THE MIDDLE CLASS FOR NON
COLLEGE BOUND YOUNG PEOPLE.
AFTER COMPLETING APPRENTICESHIP.
A MULTI YEAR PROGRAM MUCH LIKE
COLLEGE THAT INCLUDES BOTH
CLASSROOM AND PAID ON THE JOB
TRAINING. YOU'VE EARNED A
PROFESSION THAT CAN PROVIDE
FAMILY SUSTAINING WAGES AND
BENEFITS FOR A LIFETIME. EVEN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. NEARLY THREE
QUARTERS OF OUR PREMISES ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND ONE IN FIVE
COMES FROM THE FOSTER CARE AND
MANSON YOUTH OR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. OUR APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS CARRY WITH THEM HUGE
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL VALUE AND
ARE QUITE LITERALLY LIFE
CHANGING. SO ALTHOUGH WE SUPPORT
BUILDING MORE STUDENT HOUSING
AND AS SUCH ARE SPONSORS OF A
SENATE BILL TO DO JUST THAT WE
ARE NOT SUPPORTIVE OF DOING SO
IN A WAY THAT HURTS WORKERS
EMBOLDENS THE UDERGROUND
ECONOMY AND SENDS THE MESSAGE TO
BLUE COLLAR KIDS. THAT THERE ARE
PERTINENT EASE ARE SOMEHOW LESS
OF A PRIORITY TO CALIFORNIA THAN
THEIR COLLEGE BOUND PIERCED. ON
BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERSHIP AND
ESPECIALLY OUR SEVENTY TWO
THOUSAND APPRENTICES WE URGE A
NO VOTE UNLESS THIS BILL IS
AMENDED TO INCLUDE LABOR
PROTECTIONS. SO AS TO AVOID A
TRULY CLASSES CONSEQUENCE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND IF THERE'S A
SECOND WITNESS WHO WOULD LIKE
TWO MINUTES- MAY HAVE THAT AND
IF YOU'D LIKE TO COME TO THE
TABLE BECAUSE YOU I THINK WE'RE
OKAY RIGHT ALL RIGHT SO THEN
I'LL TAKE- OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
WHO ARE HERE IN PERSON AND THEN
I'LL GO TO THE PHONES. SO YOUR
NAME MAN- WE REPRESENT. MY NAME
IS MARK MORTAR OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE MID VALLEY BUILDING
TRADES- PAST BUSINESS MANAGER OF
YOU A LOCAL TWO TWO EIGHT UP IN
MARYSVILLE CALIFORNIA- I WANT TO
SAY THAT- WE ARE- FOR THIS IF
THEY WOULD MEAN THIS. AND
PROTECT WORKERS PROTECT THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED- THE STATE
ACCREDITED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS I CAN TELL YOU ON THE
LAST ONE THAT BUILT A THREE
MILLION DOLLAR FACILITY NORTH OF
SACRAMENTO. AND THEY'VE BUILT
THOUSANDS OF HOUSES AND SHE GOES
STATE FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
WE NEVER PUT AN APPRENTICE ON
THE JOB. WE NEVER SENATE
JOURNEYMEN OUT TO GO TO WORK.
AND THEY WON'T DO IT IF THEY
DON'T HAVE TO SO IF YOU COULD
JUST PLEASE AMEND THIS BILL. DO
THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE REQUIREMENTS THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO WORK WITH THE
STATE ACCREDITED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS AND IT'S A WIN WIN FOR
EVERYBODY. SO ONCE AGAIN I THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE.
HAVE A GOOD DAY. THANK YOU SO
WE'LL TAKE THAT AS THE SECOND
WITNESS- IN OPPOSITION- WITH THE
TWO MINUTES BUT NOW MOVING
FORWARD JUST YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH THANK
YOU MY NAME IS FORTINO CARRILLO.
AND REPRESENTED A HIDDEN FROST
INSULATORS AND ALLIED WORKERS
UNION LOCAL SIXTEEN. AND WE ARE
HERE STANDING WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING
TRADES. OPPOSING THIS BILL
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID
BROWN I WORK FOR LOCAL ONE
EIGHTEEN I WORKERS. AND WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I WOULD NO
CHILL OUT LOCAL SIXTEEN
INSULATORS AND WE JOIN IN THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES. ALESSI
SUMMONED. THEM IF WE OPPOSE THE
- HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS MITCHELL BACK TILL WITH THE
IRON WORKERS DISTRICT COUNCIL-
WERE IN OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOSE
DURAN I WORK FOR A LOCAL ONE
EIGHTEEN I WORKERS AND WE STAND
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN A POSITION OF THIS AMENDED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
WAYNE ATKINS. I WORK WITH THE
LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN IRON WORKERS
UNION AND WE STAND WITH THIS
CALIFORNIA'S. BUILDINGS EARNINGS
RATES COMMITTEE TO. I OPPOSE
THIS UNLESS IT IS AMENDED THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JOHN HERSHEY WITH UNITED
ASSOCIATION OF PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN AND WE STAND OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN FOR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SECOND
MOST YEARS BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. AND
WE STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION UNTIL BILL
WAS AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU
. HI GOOD AFTERNOON JUST AGREE
WITH THE OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL THREE S. STAND WITH THE
BUT STATE BUILDING TRADES. AND
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SEE NO OTHER
OPPOSITION IN THE- IN THE
BUILDING. I'LL GO TO THE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR IF THERE
ARE ANY- ME TOOS IN OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINES. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO A. B.
SIXTEEN OH TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE ZERO. WE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY SIX NAME IN THE GROUP
YOU'RE WITH. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON GRETCHEN NEAR SOME
CROWD GRADUATED CAL POLY
HUMBOLDT AND SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF BY B. W. FIVE SIX NINE OR
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED YOU KNOW
LIKE TUITION THE POWER
PROFESSIONALS OF SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY. IN OPPOSITION A
LOT THE BILL'S AMENDED TO
INCLUDE PREVAILING WAGES LABOR
PROVISION BANCOR THE CONCLUSION
CLEARLY. OPERATOR TO THE NEXT
PERSON ON THE LINE. LINE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS CHANGE
THEIR ACTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL OF LEADERS AND WE
ARE IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION A.
B. SIXTEEN OH TWO UNLESSAMENDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED NINETEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
J. DILUTES THE PRESIDENT
IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
AMENDED. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
FIFTEEN. KIM BALDRIDGE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE IN
OPPOSITION WITHOUT THE AMENDMENT
LANGUAGE. THANK YOU. BLIND ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE. DOMINO'S
MY GRILLING WITH THE HELP OF A
TRADE WORKING WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES OPPOSITIONAL UP
MONDAY. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN. WHITE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN OR MY COULD OPEN. NEVER
CREDO MOBILE BOARD THIRTY ONE
TEAMSTERS UNION I OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED EIGHTY SIX YOU DON'T TO
THE CARD. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE. HELLO MY
NAME IS ONE RESULTS WITH
DISTRICTS UP TO SIXTEEN PRINTERS
NOT OUTRAGEOUS AND WE STARTED
WITH THE BILL WHAT WE FOUND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS I'M AND- THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO. WHILE THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT COUNCIL OF
LABORERS AND WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION BUT STATE BUILDING
TRADES DEPARTMENT OF. THANK YOU
. LINE EIGHTY ONE. BUT WHEN I
WAS DONE QUITE WELL THE IBEW
LOCAL FOUR TWENTY EIGHT WE ARE
DOING THE STATE BUDGET IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BY NINETY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROB STOKER
PRESENTING SHOULD METAL WORKERS
LOCAL ONE OH FOUR AND ALSO THE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL OF ALAMEDA COUNTY AND WE
STRONGLY STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. AB SIXTEEN OH TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINED UP ONE
HUNDRED AND NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEDICAL ROLLED LIVE WITH THE
LABORERS DISTRICT COUNCIL IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BUILD OF
THE AMENDED TO PROTECT WORKERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS
DOUG MANAGING ALREADY UP WITH
THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD F
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AREN'T YOU
COUNTY AND WE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE AT NINETY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS CANNELLA
BUSINESS AGENT ORGANIZER FOR
IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT DUE TO THE LACK OF WORKER
PROTECTIONS IN THIS BILL I WILL
GO TO THE NEXT CALLER IN AN
OPPOSITE NAME JUST NAME AND THE
GROUP YOU'RE WITH WILL GO THE
NEXT GOT. LINE. EIGHTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS DAN WITH
BOTH THE SAN DIEGO IRONWORKERS
LOCAL TWO TWO NINE WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED TO AB
SIXTY NO TO. THANK YOU. WHY NOT
ONE HUNDRED TWO. YES THE BILL
CHISHOLM LOCAL A TRUCKERS UNION
AND WE STAND IN OPPOSITION. TO
SIXTEEN UNTIL AS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. WHAT LINE OF ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN. WHITE ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS PAM
KRAGEN WITH THAT YOUR COUNCIL
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES UNIONS AND WE STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. NINE EIGHTY. HAPPY TUESDAY
MY NAME'S JAKE WOULD- WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL TWELVE WE'RE
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN OPPOSITION LET THE MEN THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEDINA AND
MEMBERS THIS IS BOB ZERO ON
BEHALF THE INTERNATIONAL UNION
OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
BOTH DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
AND THIRTY SIX AND WE OPPOSE THE
BILL UNLESS AMENDED AND URGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. TO
CONSIDER OUR LANGUAGE. THANK YOU. ONE ONE HUNDRED TEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A TIMOTHY
JEFFRIES- THE BOILERMAKERS
INTERNATIONAL- I SPENDING A
REPRESENT THEM IN- WELL THERE'S
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTEEN OH TWO
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU THERE.
THANK YOU. LINE. SEVENTY NINE. I
AM SEVENTY NINE- MIKE
DEVELOPMENT. RIGHT. ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT. YEAH JEFF THE NAME
OF THE OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
THREE IN OPPOSITION AMENDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WIND. ONE
HUNDRED TWELVE. HELLO MY NAME IS
DANNY BERNARDINI I REPRESENT THE
NINETEEN AFFILIATES OF THE NAPA
SOLANO BUILDING TRADES AND I
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRADE SUPPOSES
BILL UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FIND. ONE HUNDRED
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOE SANDERS AND BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR LOCAL NINE
ONE THREE DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES. WE ARE- JOINING THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. WHITE ONE HUNDRED FIVE. YES
YES WE CAN AREA. NOT YET OKAY
THANK YOU FOR OUR WORKERS LOCAL
FOUR SIXTEEN. AND I JUST OUR
BUDGET WE STAND WITH STATE
BUILDING TRADES HAVE A CLOSING
THE SERVICE ABOUT THAT AB
SIXTEEN OKAY. THANK YOU. Y.
EIGHT NINE. I AM MARIE OD
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
ORANGE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL WITH FORTY EIGHT
LOCAL UNION DISTRICT CUNCIL THE
LARGEST COUNTY TRADE COUNCIL IN
OUR STATE WE OPPOSE AB SIXTEEN
OH TWO UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED ONE. HI COREY ALLMOND WITH
TEAMSTERS LOCAL EIGHT FIVE SIX
AND WE ARE JOINING THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
ANALYSTS AMENDED SB SIX YOU KNOW
TO. THANK YOU. BLIND. ONE
HUNDRED THIRTEEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS JAY P. ANTHONY WITH DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN KIND OF THE
KNOWLEDGE RIGHT YOU CAN WE STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED TO AB
SIXTEEN ALSO. THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT. AND
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. I'D ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX- FALLING LAUGHING
WITH THE OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL CITY STANDING WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED. THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED FORTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CAROL CHEN CEO OF THE SAN DIEGO
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL FAMILY HOUSING
CORPORATION AND BUSINESS MANAGER
OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
WE STAND WITH THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY
SIXTEEN OH TWO AND LESS THAN
AND- THANK YOU. LINE NINETY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON STRIP
ROBERTS WITH DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN LOCAL UNION TO NINETY
FOUR INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES ON
THE STAND IN OPPOSITION AND
THAT'S AMENDED THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES TO ASSEMBLY BILL. ONE SIX ZERO TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHY NOT. ONE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MAKING WITH GLAZERS LOCAL SEVEN
EIGHTEEN DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN. WE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED. HELLO MY NAME IS ONE
CALDERON I'M A BUSINESS
REPRESENTED WITH DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES WE STAND
SOLIDARITY WITH THEIR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS OF THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
HOMELESS AMENDED TO A. B.
SIXTEEN OH TWO. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE OF ONE HUNDRED FORTY
SIX. I JUST UNLOCKED WITH
TOMBALL DOWN OR BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES. WE STAND IN
STRONG OPPOSITION BUT THE STATE. THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS COREY BROWN
RICE WITH THE VALLEY BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO SIXTEEN OH TWO
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE A ONE FIFTY THREE. SHE. HELLO MY NAME IS JAMES FOSTER
NUMBER DISCOUNT SIXTEEN PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES AND WE STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES AND
OPPOSITE OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO. HELLO THIS IS
DAVID BEANIE WITH THE SANTA
CLARA AND SAN BENITO COUNTIES
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE JOINED THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL AND LEFT AMENDED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THAT TIME.
THANK YOU ARE DO WE HAVE ANY
TWEETERS HERE AND SIDE. THE
BUILDING THAT'S IN ANY CLEANERS
TO GO TO THE AT&T MODERATOR IF
WE HAVE ANY TWEETERS ON THE LINE
. ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THE END ZERO THE
COMMAND AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE A COUPLE PEOPLE-
QUEUED UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WHILE WE PROVIDE THEM WITH WINE.
OKAY.
WHY NOT ONE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE.
IT'S GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THAT THE TENDER MULTI
WHAT THE CSU CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE- WE DO NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL AT
THIS TIME BUT I'VE HAD SOME
PRELIMINARY CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE ABOUT OUR
SYSTEM WIDE HOUSING NEEDS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING ENGAGED AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE AT NINETY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON DAHLE
RADFORD LABORERS LOCAL ONE
EIGHTY FIVE OUT OF SACRAMENTO
AND- WE DO STAND IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL NOT SUBMITTED TO
INCLUDE SKILLED AND TRAINED
LANGUAGE- I'VE WORKED ON-
COLLEGES MYSELF BUT WE ARE NOT
DESIGNED TO TREATMENT GO TO
INBOX NEXT CALLER NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. A. T. AND T. OPERATOR.
LINE A ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN. MY
NAME IS DAVID JOHNSON WHAT LOCAL
TWO TWO NINE NINE WORKERS WE ARE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED TO A. B. SIXTEEN ZERO
TWO. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
CALLERS ON THE LINE YEAH MOTOR.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER CALLERS AT
THIS TIME. WITH WITH THAT I'LL
I'LL GO TO THE COMMITTEE MR WITH
. US THANK YOU I THOUGHT I
APOLOGIZE THAT I WALKED IN LATE
SO MAYBE I MISSED. SOME KEY
PARTS BUT THAT MIGHT I JUST WANT
TO ASK SPECIFICALLY YOU KNOW I
AM VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF SKILLED
LABOR- WHEN PUBLIC MONEY IS
BEING USED AND THAT IS THE LAW
SO. IS THERE A DISCONNECT HERE
WHAT IS SPECIFICALLY I MEAN WE
DO NEED TO MAKE SURE IT'S
SKILLED LABOR THAT WOULD BE
BUILDING- ON THESE CAMPUSES SO
WHAT IS THE- THE LANGUAGE. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE THE RIGHT
PERSON TO SPEAK OR MAYBE THE-
MAYBE THE- REPRESENTATIVE OF.
OKAY SO THE QUESTION IS WOULDN'T
WHEN SKILLED LABOR TO READY BE
REQUIRED IF IT'S STATE MONEY
THAT IS BEING ISSUED A
PREVAILING WAGE S REQUIRED SO
THE PAYMENT OF PREVAILING WAGES
THE COR CHOIR WENT WITH PUBLIC
MONEY IT'S NOT A REQUIREMENT TO
USE A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE TO SKILLED AND TRAINED
LANGUAGE IS SEPARATE FROM THE-
PREVAILING WAGE THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE SEEKING AND THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THAT A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE. OF WORKERS ON SITE
ARE GRADUATES OF STATE
ACCREDITED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS WHICH THEN TURNS THE
SYSTEM TO ALLOW US TO TAKE IT
MORE APPRENTICES HAVE
APPRENTICES ON THESE ACTUAL JOB
SITES AND BRING MORE INTO THEIR-
TRAINING CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THAT SO- CLARIFICATION SO I
THIS IS HAVE YOU HAD DISCUSSIONS
WITH LABOR THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY YES WE HAVE AND- I'M I'M
FULL SUPPORT OF THE CONCEPT HERE
WHICH IS MAKE SURE WE HAVE.
BUDGET CONTRACTORS AT PAY
PREVAILING WAGE IN THE DON'T
HAVE SHADY APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS WHICH IS BEEN THREE
PEOPLE NEVER HAVE ALLOWED PEOPLE
TO MOVE UP IN THE BUILDING
TRADES- A CAREER PATH THAT THIS
IS A COMPLICATED ISSUE RELATED
TO NOT ONLY THIS PUBLIC PROJECTS
BUT ALSO HOUSING AND SO I KNOW
THERE'S CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES AND WITH
LEADERSHIP IN BOTH HOUSES ON HOW
TO CRAFT THAT. THAT TO FIND
COMPROMISE SO I'M COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON THIS WORK WERE AYE
AYE AYES TO WILL BE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS- THIS IS A BUDGET
THING AS WELL AS YOU KNOW SO THE
CAN CURRENTLY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THIS AS WE GO THROUGH THE
BUDGET. PROCESS SO CORRECT YEAH
. SO YOU'RE COMMITTING TO CAN TO
WORK TO. A SOLUTION YEAH. FROM I
THINK ARE WE WILL I THINK THERE
WAS A GRAND THERE IS AN OPTION
LAST YEAR ON IT BUT TO CONFUSE
THINGS A SEPARATE BELT LIKE A
DIFFERENT THRESHOLD TO MAKE SURE
THERE WAS. AT LEAST ONE MORE
THAN ONE BID ON A PROJECT AND
MAKE SURE AS A CERTAIN THRESHOLD
SO THAT COULD BE IN THE MIX OR
COULD BE OTHER OPTIONS I KNOW
THAT THAT. BUILDING TRADES
LEADERSHIP ALONG WITH OUR
LEADERSHIP IN THE ASSEMBLY
THEY'RE- TALKING ABOUT OPTIONS
THANK. THANK YOU AS WELL AS
THERE IS AND THEN I'LL GO TO
MISTER SONNTAG WELL FIRST OF ALL
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK THE
AUTHOR- FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I THINK IT'S A GREAT
CONCEPT ONE OF THINGS I HEAR
MOST FROM EMPLOYERS IN MY
DISTRICT AND- WHICH ARE
UNIVERSITIES AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- IS THAT IS REALLY HARD
TO RECRUIT A WORKFORCE WHEN THEY
CAN'T FIND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY WORK
AND I THINK THAT THIS DOES A
GREAT JOB OF TRYING TO ADDRESS
TRAVEL FOR STUDENTS AND FACULTY
ON WHICH IS. DEEPLY NEEDED I DO
HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS IN REGARDS
TO THE FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THAT
WOULD BE ATTACHED TO THIS WOULD
THIS BE AN INITIAL WOULD THERE
BE A BREAKDOWN OF INITIAL
FUNDING THROUGH CERTAIN BUDGET
YEARS WE JUST THIS BUT- FOR THE
NEXT THIRTY YEARS HOW HOW IS
GONNA ACTUALLY WORK IN THE
FINANCIAL POINT- WELL THIS
BUILDS UPON. WHAT WE DID LAST
YEAR WE PUT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN LAST YEAR. AT AND THE
REALITIES WE GOT. AN AMAZING
AMOUNT NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS
AND NOT ENOUGH MONEY TO GO
AROUND TO FUND THESE PROJECTS
THROUGH. SO THAT SHOWS THAT THE
DEMAND IS THERE. FOR SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS TO PUT PEOPLE TO
WORK AND HELP WITH THE HOUSING
CRISIS SO. WE'RE COMING BACK
THIS YEAR. YOU KNOW DOUBLING UP
FOR EVEN MORE. WITH FIVE BILLION
ONE TIME INFUSION OF- FIVE
BILLIONDOLLARS OF ONE TIME.
INVESTMENT AS YOU KNOW FROM THE
BUDGET DISCUSSIONS WITH RON-
THERE IS ONE TIME MONEY AND TO
HAVE A- SURGE IN ONE TIME TAX
REVENUE IN THIS YEAR'S-
PROJECTED BUDGET. SO THE IDEA
THERE IS TO USE SOME OF THOSE
ONE TIME MONIES. FOR CAPITAL
PROJECTS WHICH WE KNOW IS IT IS
VERY TIMELY WITH THE-
CONVERSATIONAL WE NEED TO DO
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET RELATED.
AGAIN MEASURES AND SO FORTH THIS
IS A GREAT USE OF ONE TIME
INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY. TO DEAL
WITH SOME OF THE- UP. IT IN
CALIFORNIA. HOUSING CALL
PORTABILITY. I'M QUESTION I DO
HAVE IS. JUST AND AGAIN WHAT
WOULD. WOULD IT. WHEN WOULD IT
WOULD BE A THIRTY YEAR LOAN WITH
THOSE PAYMENTS START YOU KNOW
IMMEDIATELY I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PAY BACK
WOULD BE ON THIS IF WE'RE GONNA
HAVE THIS RECURRING REVOLVING
ACCOUNT TO LAST FOR YOU KNOW.
HOWEVER MANY YEARS DECADES TO BE
GREAT TO IT EMBRITTLEMENT IMP
YEAH EXACTLY I'M JUST CURIOUS TO
KNOW WHAT THE PAYMENT WOULD BE
BACK AND THEN LASTLY I AM I AM
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT A SEAT
YOU KNOW MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
USING SKILLED AND TRAINED AND
I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT YOU WILL
STILL BE WORKING- WITH THE
BUILDING TRAINS ON THIS ISSUE I
THINK IT'S VITALLY IMPORTANT.
AND I ALSO WANT TO BRING UP YOU
KNOW. WHAT I'M ALSO FEARFUL OF
IS THAT IF WE DON'T REALLY
ADDRESS OUR SEEK WHAT ISSUE WHEN
IT COMES TO HOUSING WHEN IT
COMES TO PROJECTS LIKE THIS. AND
EITHER HAVE A STREAMLINED
APPROACH. BUILT IN AND OR AN
EXEMPTION FOR THESE PROJECTS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE FUNDED BY
THE STATE- THAT. THEY COULD TAKE
LONGER AND BECOME EVEN MORE
COSTLY- SO. I WOULD JUST KIND OF
LOVE YOUR YOUR FEEDBACK ON THAT
. YES OF THE MIDDLE ONE I THINK
WE ANSWERED MR WHEN THAT SKILLED
AND TRAINED. WE'RE COMMITTED TO
I'M COMMITTED TO HAVING THAT
TYPE OF PROVISION IN THIS POLICY
IN THIS BILL OR IN THE BUDGET
WHICH WOULD ACTUALLY FIND THIS
EITHER WAY- THE FIRST THING ON
THE ON THE PAY BACK IT IS TO
JUST BE AS THE CHANCELLOR FROM.
UC SAN DIEGO COASTAL SAID.
ESSENTIALLY AS OPPOSED TO
BORROWING MONEY FROM WELLS FARGO
THEY BY AND YOU KNOW PAY THAT.
5% OR WHATEVER INTEREST THE
PHARMACY TO CALIFORNIA'S THE TO
BE LOWER AFTER THIS PAYMENTS
THEY BEACON OF WITHOUT THE
INTERESTED BE LOWER PRINCIPAL
PAYMENTS IN THE BILL TO USE THAT
SAVINGS TO PASS ON TO HAVE. A
CHEAPER HOUSING FOR THEIR
STUDENTS- OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THEY WOULD PAY BACK THE LOAN
JUST AS A TRADITIONAL NON THEY
WOULD IN THE COMMERCIAL- WORLD.
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE ON
REGULATIONS WHEN THAT LOAN
PAYMENT WOULD BE DO- PROBABLY
SIMILAR TO CONSTRUCTION LOAN
IT'S NOT. RIGHT AT DAY ONE YOU
HAVE TO WAIT TO YOUR PROJECT
FINISHES BEFORE YOU CAN START
COLLECTING. RENT FROM THAT
PROJECT SO- BUT WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT ISSUE AND THEN LASTLY ON
THAT ON THE SYKORA- I DON'T HAVE
AN ANSWER FOR THAT THAT'S YOU
KNOW OTHER POLICY BILLS I DO
NOTE THAT IN THE UNIVERSITY THEY
HAVE THEIR OWN- PROCESS. TO
APPROVE PROJECTS INSTEAD IS THE
CSU SO THEY GO THROUGH THE-
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS. THROUGH
THAT. SO- I CAN'T HAPPEN IT'S
FOR YOU THERE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- GO TO MR SANTIAGO. THANK
YOU MR NOT A HUGGABLE THE TIME
FINANCE COUPLE QUESTIONS AND
THEN LET OTHER MEMBERS IF YOU'RE
OKAY WITH THAT YEAH AND SO- I
APPRECIATE THE HOUSING- EFFORT
BECAUSE I THINK WITH MUCH NEEDED
UNITED TALKED ABOUT THIS OVER AN
OVERSIGHT BY APPLAUD THE EFFORTS
AND THANK YOU. I MEAN IT WOULD
BE UNPRECEDENTED USE PUBLIC
FUNDS- IN A WAY DID NOT AND
INCLUDE A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. AND I KIND OF
DIFFERENTIATE AND WHEN I LOOKED
AT A PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT.
VERSUS SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. NOW I WAS ON A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD ALL
FOLKS HERE HEARD ME SAY THAT
OVERALL RATING. BUT BUT THERE IS
A BIG DIFFERENCE BECAUSE PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS WITHOUT A
COMPLIANCE PIECE TO IT. LEADS TO
THE SAME ACTIONS THAT WERE
TRYING TO PREVENT SO OFTEN TIMES
AT LEAST WHEN I GOT ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD. AND
THEY HAD A FRAMEWORK FOR PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT. WITHOUT A
ROBUST FULLY FUNDED- COMPLIANCE
PROGRAM IT REALLY DID MEAN
ANYTHING. THAT'S WHY. WE
IMPLEMENT WE WENT TOWARDS A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
BECAUSE- A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. REALLY DOES HAVE ALL
THE COMPLIANCE PIECES IN THE
FRAMEWORK. TO DO WHAT WE WANTED
TO DO. GIVE EXAMPLES BECAUSE WE
HAD. WITH GOOD CONTRACTORS OF
THE DOUBT ABOUT IT BUT WE HAD
SOME BAD ACTORS. WE'RE ON PAPER
IT SHOWED THAT THEY PAID THE
FORTY HOURS WHEN THE AFFIDAVIT-
OR WHEN YOU TALK TO THE EMPLOYEE
WORK FORCE OF ONLY PAY TWENTY
DOLLARS. AND IT WASN'T UNTIL WE
PROTECT. WORKFORCE IN PLACE BUT-
WITH WITH THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE YOU HAVE A
BONAFIDE. PROCESS THAT ACTUALLY
DOES ENSURE THAT THE EMPLOYEE
GETS PAID WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE PAID. BECAUSE THERE IS
THERE IS. ADVOCACY AND
REPRESENTATION FOR THE EMPLOYEE.
A SIDE OF ALL THAT THE PROJECTS
ARE MUCH BETTER. WE WENT FROM A
PROGRAM THAT WAS DOING OVER RUNS
10% AND ABOVE AND GETTING-
GETTING- SETTLED THROUGH COURT
PROCESSES. TO A PROGRAM THAT
WAS. THAT WAS ON TIME AND THE
PROJECT WILL WORK IN THE WAY
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO SO THERE
IS A- BENEFIT TO THE- TO THE
PROGRAM NOT JUST A DRIVE TO SEE
HOW CHEAP YOU CAN GET THE
PROGRAM WHEN YOU BID. ON ON
THOSE ON THE LOWEST BID. SO THIS
IS A BENEFIT TO THAT THAT'S
WHAT. I THINK IT'S WORTH THE
CONVERSATION OF HAVING. A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE IN
. THE YOU MISTER MCCARTY THAT
FINDS MY MOM YOU THAT WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THE PUBLIC ABOUT.
WHEN I ALSO WORKED AT THE BORDER
LEGAL WE DID DO ON PROJECTS THAT
WERE SAID TO HAVE HAD SKILLED
AND FOR A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT. MULTI TASK. SWEEP THE
RATE WHATEVER ONE CAUGHT WHERE
YOU. CLEARLY ON PAPER LOOK LIKE
IT BUT IT WASN'T. A. N. N. IN
THESE WERE ACTIONS DONE WITH CAL
OSHA DEPARTMENT OF IT ALSO
RELATIONS I MEAN GO ON THE BILL
ALPHABET LISTED ET D. B. O. WE-
EN FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. SO THERE
IS A BENEFIT TO DOING THAT WITH
A PUBLIC FUNDS. WHAT I STRUGGLE
WITH THE ISN'T THE HOUSING ISN'T
THE CONCEPT ISN'T ISN'T THAT
DOING THIS IT'S THAT WE DON'T
INSURE THAT THESE DOLLARS. ARE
IN THE WAY WE WANT THEM TO LIKE
IT'S- LIKE ALL THE THINGS THAT
WE SAID AN APPEAL A WHICH REALLY
ARE. KIND OF SKILLED TRAINED
WORKFORCE ENSURES THAT WE DO
THAT THAT WE WILL GET THAT SET
OUTCOME. AND YOU KNOW. AND I'M
WONDERING WHAT. KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS YOU'VE HAD ABOUT
FIVE BECAUSE I STRUGGLE WITH
THAT PIECE AND I KNOW. I KNOW
YOU'VE YOU'VE TOLD ME THAT YOU
THAT YOU WERE WORK WORKING ON IT
BUT I'D LIKE TO HEAR- HUH LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT. YOUR THOUGHTS ON
SKILLED TRAINED WORKFORCE IN.
THE CONVERSATION THAT HAPPENED
HERE TODAY. YEAH YEAH AS I SAID
EARLIER THIS THIS WAS- TIMING I
PROPOSED LAST YEAR. IT IT GOT
TAKEN OVER IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
WE NEVER HAD A CHANCE TO PUT
SKILLED AND TRAINED IN THIS
BILL. THAT LEADERSHIP IN THE IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DECLINED TO
PUT SKILLED AND TRAINED IN THAT
TWO BILLION DOLLAR INCLUSION
LAST YEAR. I THOUGHT I SUPPORT
IT I'M TRYING TO FIND A WAY HOW
WE CAN HAVE IT IN THIS BILL IN
THE BUDGET DISCUSSIONS. THE
BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS IT'S AN
pONGOING THING MY UNDERSTANDING.
THAT- THE BUILDING TRADES. STATE
BUILDING TRIP STRAYED'S
LEADERSHIP AND OUR SOME
BELIEVERS HAVE ARE WORKING ON
THIS AND- I'M HOPEFUL CAN BE
INCLUDED. IN THIS AND OUR BUDGET
ACTION IN THE COMING MONTHS. YES
YOU CAN GO BACK TO THE QUESTIONS
ARE COMPLICATED RIGHT MR LEVINE
AND THEN DOCTOR WEB. YEAH WELL
THE FIRST WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SOME NUMBER I THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BILL YOU'RE
HITTING ON A VERY OBVIOUS IS A
SUCH A- IMPORTANT TOPIC RIGHT
NOW WE WANT TO EXPAND.
ENROLLMENT IN ALL OF HER
UNIVERSITIES AS MUCH AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN AND THAT DEMANDS
LIKE A HOUSING SOLUTION WHETHER
IT'S COMMUNITY COLLEGE. CSU YOU
NAME IT- IN THIS CONVERSATION
THAT WE'RE HAVING IT IT BRINGS
ME BACK. TO TWENTY FOURTEEN
WHICH I KNOW WAS A LIFETIME AGO
I DON'T THINK ANYONE BESIDES THE
CHAIR AND I WERE MEMBERS AT THE
TIME- ON A BILL THAT IF HI.
CLEAR THE COBWEBS OUT WAS SB
SEVEN- THE DATA STEINBERG AND-
AND CANNELLA HAD AUTHORED
TOGETHER AND IT WAS ABOUT
PREVAILING WAGE WHEN PUBLIC
MONIES WAS INVOLVED THIS IS THAT
ANYONE IN THE GALLERIES. YEAH
THEY'VE GOT SOME HEAD HEADS
NODDING BACK THERE I KNOW IT'S
JUST LIKE GOT GOT A HIBERNATION
BE LIKE I REMEMBER THAT SO-
REALLY CHALLENGING DIFFICULT ON
BILL AND ERE WE ARE- EIGHT
YEARS LATER AND- IT'S AS THOUGH-
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT
SOME OF THE OTHER. YOU KNOW
FINER PIECES OF THAT-
PARTICULARLY IN THIS SPACE. AND
AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT
CONVERSATION AND SO NOT TO
BELABOR IT- WHAT IS SO
FASCINATING TO ME AND WHY
YOU'RE- SO APPROPRIATE TO AUTHOR
THIS BILL AS IT GOES TO THE
POLICY COMMITTEES. IS BECAUSE OF
YOUR ROLE IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- SO. YOU KNOW I DON'T
REALLY THINK OF THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AS THE-
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
COMMITTEE OR HOUSING COMMITTEE
THAT DIDN'T IS THIS DOUBLE
REFERRED TO ANOTHER COMMITTEE SO
THAT'S THAT'S FASCINATING IN ITS
IN ITS OWN WAY- AND THEN- AND SO
YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
FINANCING. FINER DETAILS- WHICH-
IT ISN'T REALLY ARE COMMITTEE
EITHER WE JUST LIKE TO MAKE SURE
STUDENTS HAVE A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEAD AND- AND THAT'S IMPORTANT.
TO KEEP THE COST DOWN BECAUSE WE
KNOW. THAT FEES TUITION ALL OF
THAT THAT'S ALMOST A CONTROLLED
COST GIVEN THE BUDGET THE WAY
IT'S PLAYED OUT OVER THE PAST
DECADE BUT WHAT'S NOT UNDER
CONTROL. IS OUR COST OF LIVING-
WHICH IS JUST SPIRALED OUT OF
CONTROL IT'S TOTALLY OUT OF
HAND- AND SO- SO IT'S REALLY ON
I THINK THE PRESSURE IS BACK ON
THIS BUDGETARY PROCESS. LIKE HOW
DO WE DEAL WITH THIS IMPORTANT
LABOR ISSUE THIS COMMITTED THESE
BILLS ARE GOING TO LABOR
COMMITTEE OR HOUSING COMMITTEE
OR ANY OF THESE OTHER
COMMITTEES. AND WE DON'T REALLY
LOOK AT THOSE ISSUES HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT GETS THE PROPER
HERE HEARING. IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS AND DOT. SO I JUST
WANTED TO REFLECT ON HOW MUCH OF
THAT RESPONSIBILITY JUST REALLY
BECAUSE BACK TO YOU AS THE
AUTHOR AND THAT THAT YOU'RE
TAKING THAT ON AND I REALLY
RESPECT. YOU IN IN A IN THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
OTHERS WHO HAVE REALLY TAKEN
THAT ON SO THANK YOU. YEAH SURE
ANSWER. YEAH I WILL KNOW THAT
THIS IS- THIS IS ONE OF THE I
THINK THE FIRST BILL INTRODUCED
WE CAME BACK INTO SESSION I
THINK IT'S ONE OF THE CRITICAL
ISSUES WE'RE DEALING WITH.
HOUSING CRISIS AND THE COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS YOU'RE
RIGHT. AND YOU KNOW. WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE IN THE
BUSINESS OF. FOCUSING ON HOUSING
WE WE'VE NEVER BEEN CALIFORNIA.
AT THE LEGISLATURE WITH THE CALL
JUST TAKE CARE ON THEIR OWN THEY
BORROW MONEY FROM THE BANKS AND
THEY BUILD THEIR HOUSING AND AS
WE SEE IT'S WOEFULLY INADEQUATE.
SO FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR'S AS YOU
KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO PUT OUR OWN
MONEY ON THE TABLE AND HELP.
BUILD MORE STUDENT HOUSING. AND
WE SAW SO MANY PEOPLE APPLY THE
LAST FEW WEEKS. BOB CHARTS IS
LIKE AND WE'RE PICKING WINNERS
AND LOSERS FROM COLLEGES AND ALL
OF YOUR DISTRICTS. AND I WANT TO
PICK MORE WINNERS. AND WE WANT
TO PICK WINNERS AND FAMILIES ARE
GOING TO COLLEGE AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WITH THE WORKERS. ARE
TAKING CARE WHEN THEY BUILT IT
SO THAT'S THE THING THAT WE'RE
DOING HERE- I WILL KNOW THAT
THIS IS JOINING AUTHORED BY.
MYSELF CERVANTES MR. MEDINA MR
TANKS THE TANK AND I ARE THE
BUDGET LEADS ON THIS ISSUE WE
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS.
THE LAST FEW DAYS WE'VE BEEN
COMMUNICATING WITH. OUR SPEAKER
ABOUT THIS THIS IS A PRIORITY
WE'RE WELL AWARE OF THAT.
UNDERLYING LABOR ISSUE. AND
WE'RE COMMITTED TO MAKE SURE. WE
GET IT RIGHT AND IT'S A WIN WIN
WIN FOR CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I WANT TO THANK MR
LEVINE FOR TAKING HIS BACK.
DIGITAL SERIOUSLY MEMORY LANE
YEAH. TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN. YES
BEFORE BEFORE I GO TO DOCTOR
WEBER AYE I JUST HAVE A TEXTURE
FROM MY OWN STATE BUILDING TRADE
REPRESENTATIVE- BUILD PEDAS AND-
HE TEXTING ME THAT THAT HE DID
GET A CHANCE TO SPEAK ON THE
PHONE LINE SO I JUST WANNA
RECOGNIZE BILL BELLAS AND THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES- IN
RIVERSIDETHAT THEY ARE OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED. DR WEBER. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND I JUST BRIEFLY
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
TACKLING THIS- COMPLICATED BUT
VERY CRITICAL ISSUE- YOU KNOW AS
AND WHEN HE STATED HOUSING
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. NOT ONLY
FOR STUDENTS BUT I ALSO LOVE THE
FACT THAT YOU INCLUDED FACULTY
BECAUSE THEY NEED A PLACE TO
STAY AS WELL- YOU KNOW. JUST
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE HAS SAID- IT
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOU
DO INCLUDE- THE USE OF SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE. SO AS YOU
GO BACK AND YOU TALK WITH
LEADERSHIP- PLEASE MAKE SURE TO
LET THEM KNOW THAT PRETTY MUCH
EVERYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE HAS
TALKED ABOUT IT AND YOU'VE HAD.
A LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE CALL
AND- TAX- AND SO IF WE WANT THIS
TO BE SUCCESSFUL- I'M GOING TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF IT TODAY SO
THAT IT CAN CONTINUE TO PASS IN
THE CONVERSATIONS CAN. CONTINUE
TO HAPPEN AND WE CAN FIX
WHATEVER THE ISSUE IS- AND SOME
MY HOPE IS THAT ONCE IT HIT BY
THE TIME IT GETS TO THE FLOOR.
THAT THIS ISSUE WILL BE
RESOLVED. BUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DR WEBER DR CHOI. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND- OR SO. ALTHOUGH OF
THE BILL WHICH IS A VERY
AMBITIOUS AND A VERY IMPORTANT.
I HAVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS AND
THEN ALSO WITH THE- TOLLAN IDEA
- THIS IS- TO PUT THE- HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS UC SYSTEM
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. IN A BUILDING
HOUSING. OTHER THAN- EDUCATION.
HOW TO APPROACH THE HOUSING
ISSUES- THAT'S IMPORTANT TO. SO-
WHETHER WE SHOULD DO THAT THE
THAT IS A MILE OF ARCHING YOU
KNOW THE FEELING AT THIS TIME.
MORE SPECIFICALLY IF YOU CAN
CLARIFY. OVER THIRTY YEARS SO
WITH A NO INTEREST- SO EACH
CAMPER SO WHEN THEY BORROWED THE
FUND- THEY HAVE TO PRESENT THAT
TO THE STATE THE HOW THEY WENT
OUT PAY BACK. THE LOAN AMOUNT OF
FOR THE- BUILDING PROJECT. THAT
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE QUESTION
OKAY YEAH AND US SECONDLY DO YOU
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC GUIDELINES FOR
THE CAMPUS ALMOST THE- BUILD THE
BUILDING FOR THE HOUSING FOR THE
FACULTY BECAUSE I SEE THREE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES FOR
STUDENTS FACULTY AND OTHER STAFF
MEMBERS- SO DIFFERENT CATEGORIES
I'M SURE THAT'D BE ARE
SEGREGATED- SEGREGATED ASAP
SEPARATE- SO- I'M SURE FOR THE
STUDENTS TO OR BE- JUST LACKED
APARTMENTS UP FOR. MONTH TO
MONTH- INTERNAL OR YOU TO LEASE
. OUT WOULD DE ID. WHEN THE BY
THE FOR THE ARE- FACULTY AND UP
ON ON THE STAFF MEMBERS SHOW A
WILL THIS BE THEIR OWN PURCHASE
SO WHAT WOULD THIS BE OUT FOR
AGAIN A LEASING PROGRAM- SO YOU
MENTIONED THAT THE FUN THOUGH
WHAT IS. ROLLER ROLLER ABOUT THE
AND OUT FOR IS. SO YOU GO INTO
THAT THE LEVEL YES. WHY CAN'T
AND NINE QUESTIONS NOT TO SO LET
ME TRY TO REMEMBER THEM. THE
FIRST THING IS WE'RE NOT TELLING
CAMPUS IS TO BUILD HOUSING
THEY'RE BUILDING HOUSING ANYWAY.
ALL YOU CAN SEE THIS YEAR IN
FRONT OF ALL AGES THE ISSUE IS
THAT THEY HAVE TO PAY HIGH
INTEREST RATES EVEN THIS LOW
INTEREST RATE ERA. AND THE
COMPETE BECAUSE THEY HAVE LIKE A
DEBT CAPACITY ON THE SYSTEM SO
THEY'RE BUILDING. BUILDINGS AND
STRUCTURES ON THE CAMPUS SO
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH DEBT
CAPACITY THANK THEY CAN HOUSE
ABOUT US HAVING THESE LOANS OVER
HERE IT ALLOWS THEM. TO BUILD
BUT THERE THESE PROJECTS ARE
SHOVEL READY ANYWAY THERE'S
MASSIVE DEMAND USUALLY IT'S
RISKY TO BUILD A STUDENT HOUSING
THEIR STUDENTS THERE ARE
PLAYING. I NEED A PLACE TO STAY
SO IT'S THAT'S NOT A SUPER RISKY
PROPOSITION TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING AT THESE CAMPUSES SO.
THIS JUST ALLOWS THEM TO BORROW
MONEY AT AT THE AT A LOWER RATE
AND NOT HAVE TO BE STRETCHED
WITH THE RATHER CAMPUS NEEDS
WITH THAT CAPACITY. IT'LL BE A
THIRTY YEAR. TERM JUST LIKE YOU
JUST LIKE THEY WOULD DO TODAY
WITH THE BANK THEY WOULD PAY A
PRINCIPAL PAYMENT EACH MONTH.
THEY WOULDN'T PAY THE INTERESTED
OVERALL THEIR PAYMENTS WILL BE
LOWER AS THEY BE BUT A SPREAD
THAT. TO HAVE MORE HOUSING AND
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. ON THE-
THE- WHAT TYPE OF PROJECTS IT'S
- IT ALL RENTAL I MEAN THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
CAMPUSES SO FAR I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE ANY HOMEOWNERSHIP
THEY'RE ALL. A RENTAL PROJECTS
THE OVERWHELMINGLY VAST MAJORITY
WOULD BE- STUDENTS AS AS DR
WEBER SAID THERE THAT WE MAY
MAKE ALLOW ABILITY IN THERE FOR
FACULTY AND STAFF YOU KNOW A LOT
OF STAFF FOR LOW WAGE. STAFF
THINK OF YOU KNOW THE THIRTY TWO
NINETY NINE TYPE WORKERS AT THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM THE NOT. A
PAID- YOU KNOW. HECK OF A LOT TO
BE ABLE TO AFFORD HOUSING IN
SOME OF THESE HIGH COSTS COLLEGE
TOWNS SO IT WILL BE ABLE TO BE-
UTILIZED BY THE UNIVERSITY TYPE
IN ENVIRONMENT. TO HELP ABOUT
ANSWERS SO YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
SPECIFY SO OR THE CAMPUS HOUSING
SHALL BE IT MENTAL UNITS ARE NOT
FOR PURCHASE. CORRECT I SEND YOU
YOU ALSO OUT THIS FAR AS A
REGULATIONS WE DO HAVE QUITE A
FEW OF THEM IN HERE WORKING WITH
THE STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE.
AND WE'RE NOT REINVENTING THE
WHEEL WE JUST DID THIS A FEW
MONTHS AGO WE'RE DOING IT RIGHT
NOW WITH GENERAL FUND MONEY FROM
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. AND SO WE
SPECIFY THAT THEY HAVE TO BE YOU
KNOW FINANCIALLY UNVIABLE
PROJECTS WE DON'T WANT PIE IN
THE SKY PROJECTS THAT ARE GONNA
FALL APART- SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THESE PROJECTS. A PENCIL
OUT AND THEY COULD YOU KNOW
SERVED THE PURPOSE IN TERMS TO.
AND ALSO BE TO PAY THE SERVICE
THEM SO IT IS A SIMPLE RETURN SO
WE CAN PHRASE IT AS A FI YOU ARE
PROVIDING. JUST A NO INTEREST-
THE BUILDING FUND THEM MAY
DEVELOP WORD NO EXTRA. INTEREST
IT'S JUST LIKE IF THEY HAVE TO
GO TO A COMMERCIAL. LENDERS SO
ENCOURAGING CAMPUS IS- TO-
EITHER BY WHAT BEARDED TO SOAK
UP PURCHASES ARE INCLUDED WITH
THESE FUNDS OF. RATHER THAN
BUILDING FROM THE SCRATCH- I'M
NOT SURE WHERE THAT PRESCRIPTIVE
AG I GUESS THE UNIVERSITY COULD
GO AND PURCHASE AN APARTMENT
BUILDING IF THAT ONE WAS THAT IT
WAS THERE BUT- I THINK MOST THE
PROJECT'S. DEBUT THEY'RE ABLE TO
GET MORE BANG FOR THE BUCK BY
HAVING SHARED UNITS WITH YOU
NOW- AND LOWER THE COSTS SO. I
THINK MOST NAY WOULD BUILD
THEMSELVES YEAH I HAVE A TENSE
UP BUT OF COURSE INSTANCES TO
JUST OUT OUT TO ADD ONE MORE
QUESTION. THAT THE AS YOUR HEARD
DOES SO MANY OPPOSITION STUFF
FROM- BUILDING INDUSTRY- AND- I
THOUGHT THE I WAS UNDER THE
IMPRESSION THAT THE ANY PUBLIC
HOUSING- EGG- DEMANDS OF
REQUIRES- TO HIRE- DO UNION
WORKERS- AND THE TO PAID THE
PREVAILING WAGE ANYWAY. AND THE
WHY IS IT DIFFERENT FROM THE ONE
IS- YOU'LL YOU'LL- BUILDING
PROJECT BUT THE CAMPUS IS- AND
THE EXISTING AT ALL. YEAH I
THINK WE TRY TO ANSWER THAT TOO
WITH SOME MEMBER- ONCE QUESTION
SO THIS IS PUBLIC MONEY WE
REQUIRE PREVAILING WAGE BUT AS
THAT WITNESS FROM THE STATE
CONSTRUCTION BUILDING TRADES
ALLUDED THERE'S NOT ALWAYS A
REQUIREMENT THEY HAVE SKILLED
AND TRAINED TO MAKE SURE THEY
HAVE. APPROPRIATE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS SO THAT'S SOMETHING I
SUPPORT WHAT WE'RE WE'RE WORKING
ON THAT AND WE- OUR HOPE TO HAVE
THAT INCLUDED IN THIS MEASURE IS
THERE ANY PROBLEM FOR YOU TO
ACCEPT THEY ARE AMENDMENT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WELL THOUGHT YOU
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED HERE IN FRONT
OF US TODAY'S NOT IN PRINT OR
ANYTHING BUT- YOU KNOW IF THIS
PASSES WILL GO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AND
YOU KNOW WE'LL BE WORKING WITH
WITH THE WITH THAT. BODY ON THAT
NEXT TOPIC THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE DIET MR SANTIAGO YEAH I
KNOW MY AFFECTING THE AUTHOR FOR
SITTING HERE AND- DIALOGUING
WITH THIS BECAUSE THAT'S
MEANINGFUL YOU KNOW- OFTENTIMES
WE GET. THE AUTHORS IN THEIR
BETTER AUTHORS AND OTHERS IN IN
HE'S BEEN WILLING TO ANSWER ALL
THE QUESTIONS AND GO BACK AND
FORTH AND ENCOURAGED THE PUBLIC
DEBATE AND I THINK THAT. THAT'S
ADMIRABLE I WANNA THANK YOU. FOR
DOING THAT. BUT BUT JUST TO
TOUCH BASE A LITTLE BT LIKE IF
I REMEMBER A LITTLE BIT AND
HOPEFULLY REMEMBER WHAT ACTOR
ABOUT WHAT CONVERSATION WE HAD
LAST YEAR. WAS ABOUT PRIVATE
DEVELOPMENT FOR THAT WITH A
DIFFERENT SET OF RULES THAT THE
CONVERSATION THIS YEAR IS ABOUT.
IS ABOUT LARGER DEVELOPMENT WITH
PUBLIC FUNDS AND SO THAT THAT
DOES CHANGE THE CONVERSATION. IN
TERMS OF NEEDING- TO PUSH FOR AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY WHAT DOES UPLIFT.
FAMILIES PARTICULARLY IN THIS
SPACE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PUBLIC
FUNDS. IN THE ABILITY FOR
SOMEBODY TO MAKE- A. WAGE WHERE
THEY CAN. PURCHASE A HOME AS
OPPOSED TO A WAGE WAR IT'S CLOSE
THE MINIMUM WAGE IN. THEIR STILL
RENTING IN THEIR SITUATIONS
NEVER APPROVED A PART OF THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOUSING SHOULD BE HOW TO. UPLIFT
OUR COMMUNITIES IN AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AND- YOU
KNOW THAT YOU SAID IT A COUPLE
TIMES ALREADY. THAT YOU SUPPORT
A SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
- BUT MAYBE I THINK A FURTHER
CONVERSATION. ABOUT OUR
COMMITMENT YOUR COMMITMENT TO AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM BY
SUPPORTING. OTHER STUDENTS IN IN
AND ITS DIRECT LINK- TO ADDING-
AND SUPPORTING SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE I DON'T OF ONE
OF OUR COLLEAGUES MENTIONED SB
SEVEN BUT SOMETHING SIMILAR TO
THAT THAT ALLOWS A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY TO BUILD HOUSING.
WITH SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE BECAUSE IT ALLOWS AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM TO WORK
BECAUSE IT DOES UP LIFT UP
COMMUNITIES IN THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND ONE OF THE
CAN KIND OF GET YOUR FEEDBACK ON
ON YOUR SUPPORT FOR SKILLED
TRAINED WORKFORCE AND AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM WHICH IS
CRITICAL. TO WILL REALLY TRYING
TO DO HERE NOW I REALIZE THAT
THE FIRST COMMITTEE- THE LAST
COMMITTEE AND WE WERE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION THERE MAY BE
DIFFERENT RESULT THAT. TO THE
WAY ON I'M FEELING A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THIS. THE FIRST COMMITTEE
YOU'VE SAID THAT YOU'RE GONNA
TRY TO ADDRESS THIS. AND JUST
KIND OF WANT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM IN. IN THE NEED TO ADD A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
YEAH I KNOW I. LOOK WHERE WE'RE
IN OUR BRAND NEW BUILDING ACROSS
pWAS BUILT WITH PREVAILING WAGE.
AND APPEAL LAY WHICH HAD SKILLED
AND TRAINED. WHICH MADE THEY HAD
GREAT PROGRAMS GOING TO WORK IN
THE NEIGHBORHOODS TO MAKE SURE
WE- BRING PEOPLE TO AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE A CAREER
PATH- THEY HAD APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS. SPENDING THROUGH AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THEY
COULD CHECK A BOX. LIKE SOME
CONTRACTORS TO SO LIKE I PRICE
WE'VE SEEN IT FIRST HAND WE'VE
SEEN THE PROJECTS ALL AROUND
HERE IN OUR DOWNTOWN. UTILIZES
I'D LIKE TO HAVE THIS HERE. ON
THIS ONE I KNOW THERE'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN PRIVATE
PROJECTS AND PUBLIC THIS IS A
PUBLIC THING. SO I KNOW THERE'S-
CONVERSATIONS WITH THAT LIKE I
SAID OF TO SAY IT AGAIN WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES LEADERSHIP
AND WITH OUR LEADERSHIP ON ALL
THESE. SKILLED AND TRAINED.
IDEAS FOR A BUNCH OF BILLS NOT
JUST THIS ONE ON. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BILLS THAT ARE YOU KNOW
PRIVATE DEVELOPERS IN THIS AND
THAT I THINK THIS ONE'S A LITTLE
MORE SIMPLISTIC AS YOU KNOW
BECAUSE IT'S- PUBLIC DOLLARS I
THINK. THAT ELEVATES. THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE TAXPAYERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE-
SPENDING OUR MONEY WISELY AND
NOT YOU KNOW USING YOUR MONEY TO
PAY. POVERTY WAGES AND AS YOU
NOTED- HAVE CONTRACTORS THAT YOU
KNOW. THAT- THAT- YOU KNOW DON'T
ALWAYS FOLLOW THROUGH ON THE
SPIRITUAL LAW. SO I'M I'M VERY
OPTIMISTIC THAT WE'LL BE ABLE
TO. HAVE THOSE TYPES OF SKILLED
AND TRAINED. PIECES THAT WE SAW
THAT OUR NEW BUILDING ACROSS THE
STREET. IN THIS- FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR REVOLVING FUND FOR
STUDENT HOUSING. GOOD MR
SANTIAGO. I MEAN I'M HEARING
THAT IT'S GONNA GO AND FILL. IT
BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THAT I THINK
I'M- I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT THIS
THAT I'M I'D BE WILLING TO ALLOW
US TO MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT I'M HEARING. RIGHT
MR LOW IMAGES GET CLARIFICATION
OF THAT AND- ON THAT- FROM THE
GYM THE AUTHOR. AND CLEAR LINES
OF COMMUNICATION SO I GET
EXCITED HERE. SOMETHING ALREADY
WE'RE GOING TO EASE BACK INTO
THE COMMITTEE PROCESS I KNOW YES
THE SOCIALIZATION BUT UP I DO IN
THE FALL BUT I CALLED MR
SANTIAGO NEXXAR RELIEVING THE
POINT BUT- YOU CAN SEE HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS SOME MCCARTY
AND- OF THAT MEANT THAT I DON'T
FEEL ENTIRELY COMFORTABLE
SUPPORTING THIS AT AS- AS OF IT
WAS. INITIALLY PRESENTED BUT
AFTER HEARING THE COMMITMENT AN
EXPLANATION AS TO THE FRAME OF
MIND THE CONTEXT TO A WIDER
CONVERSATION OUTSIDE OF THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IN BROADER
CONVERSATIONS IS THAT ALSO YOUR
OBSERVATION AND THEIR COMMITMENT
AS WELL. WHEN YOUR- A 100% OKAY
THANK YOU. MR FONG. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND- THINKING
TERMS MCCARTY AND- FOR. EARLIER
SO BENEFITS FROM THIS- ISSUE AND
JUST CHECK MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS JUST BELOW A SUPPORT
THE SKILLED IN THE- TRADEMARK
FORCE PEACE AND- REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU. BRING US FORWARD
I THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR TO
MAKE COLLEGES- SANTIAGO
REFERENCED ADAMS MEDINA A WELL.
BUT ONE OUT OF FIVE STUDENTS AT
THE ALCHEMY COLLEGES REQUIRE
SERVED ON FOR SEVEN YEARS-
IDENTIFIED AS HOUSING SECURE AND
SO OVER ABLE TO TACKLE THESE
ISSUES. ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL AND
TO ALSO LOOK AT. WORKFORCE
HOUSING FOR STAFF AND FACULTY I
THINK THIS CAN. ULTIMATELY BE A
WIN WIN AT THE END OF THE DAY
BUT THE SKELETAL- TRANSLATOR OF
WORK FOR SPACES CRITICAL. AND OF
THE COLLEGES ARE WE ALSO
SPONSORED A WE ALSO HAVE. A
STRONG PILLAR THERE BUT WE WERE
THERE SO. I THINK GOING FORWARD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND EFFORTS ARE ON TO STERLING-
BRING THIS FORWARD AND- OF
REALLY WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE SKILLED TRAINED.
WORKFORCE PIECE AND ARE GONE
FORTH THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. BUT NOT SEEN ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE OF HISTORY. THE FIRST
OF HIS BUT THAT IS AND THE
SECOND SECOND. TAKEN BY DR CHOI
OF THIS MCCARTY WITH YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE I THINK I'M TIRED. I'M
NOT SET HERE ASK HERE I HAVEA-
THANK YOU- I WANNA ECHO- MR
SANTIAGO AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING TIME AND DETAIL IN
ANSWERING THE QUESTIONS. OF HE
COMMITTEE AND I WOULD JUST KNOW
THAT EVERY SINGLE MEMBER OF THE-
OF THE COMMITTEE HAD QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AND TO MR LEVIN'S
POINT I DON'T REMEMBER ALSO-
TALKING ABOUT HOUSING IN THIS
COMMITTEE. PREVIOUSLY BUT AS AS
CHAIR OF HIGHER EDI WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING THAT WE PROBABLY ALL
HAVE VERY CLEAR IN OUR MINDS AND
THAT IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
HOUSING TO HIGHER EDUCATION- YOU
KNOW NOT ONLY FOR A PLACE TO
LIVE FOR STUDENTS AND THE
AFFORDABILITY OF HOUSING BUT
ALSO THE DIFFERENCE THAT HOUSING
MAKES. IN THE EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCE OF THE COLLEGE AND SO
THAT MOST UNIVERSITIES YOU KNOW
EITHER RECOMMEND VERY STRONGLY
OR OR REQUIRE RIGHT- THAT
STUDENTS LIVE ON CAMPUS BECAUSE
THAT IS SUCH A IN RAGING
EXPERIENCE IN THEIR EDUCATION SO
TO THAT END I THINK YOU KNOW
THAT WE ARE APPROPRIATELY
TALKING ABOUT HOUSING. SO AGAIN
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR I AM
VERY HAPPY TO BE A JOINT AUTHORS
SUPPORT MEASURE AND ADDRESSING
THE ONGOING CRISIS OF STUDENTS
FACULTY AND STAFF AND UNDERSTAND
AND AS YOU. AS YOU ALL EXPRESS
THE CONCERNS REGARDING THE- P.
THREE PROCESS AND I ASK AND I
KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH MY
COMMITTEE THE STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE AND OTHER STATE GROUPS SO
WE HAD A FIRST AND A SECOND. AND
I WILL- CALL ON OUR SECRETARY TO
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE
CHOI HI CHOI ATTY FONG. FONG I
BLOOM GABRIEL IRWIN IRWIN I
KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LO LO I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I CALAVERAS.
CALAVERAS I WEBER WEBER I'D.
NINE NINE ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS GALLAGHER THANK YOU. AND
NOW WE WILL GO TO SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T NEED AS MUCH- DISCUSSION
AND THAT IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AND THE TWO BILLS ARE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE. AND A. B. ITEM SIX A. B.
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT I HAD A
FIRST BY MR LEVINE AND THE
SECOND BY. MISS VALLADARES OF
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI
AYE CHOI AYE FONG. FONG I BLOOM
GABRIEL IRWIN. IRWIN I KILEY
LEVINE LEVINE I. LO LO I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I HELLO THERE.
BALLADARES I WEBER WEBER I. NINE
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDARS PASS-
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
MISTER GIBSON FIRST AND THEN.
GIPSON PERSON OKAY I WILL GO NOW
TO- ITEM NUMBER SEVEN MISTER
GIPSON.
MAY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT HR
EIGHTY SIX WHICH URGED THE
RECOGNITION OF CHARLES
UNIVERSITY MEDICINE AND SCIENCE-
CD H. AS A HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY BY THE
NATIONAL A TRUSS OF EXTORT
PRESERVATION. THIS DESIGNATION
WOULD RECOGNIZE THE SIGNIFICANT
ROLE OF CD YOU- HAS PLAYED IN
TRAINING HEALTHCARE LEADERS AND
WORKERS WHO GO ON TO SERVE OUR
STATE MOST VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR COMMUNITY
WHILE CD YOU IS CURRENTLY
RECOGNIZE- AS THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AS A
HISTORIC BLACK GRADUATE
INSTITUTION UNDERSCORE GRADUATE
INSTITUTION IT IS CURRENTLY NOT
RECOGNIZE THAT THE H. B. C. U.
THIS MEANS THAT- THAT- THIS
RECEIVED MUCH LESS FEDERAL
SUPPORT. TO SERVE ITS UNDERGRAD
STUDENTS THE H. B. C. U. THE
UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION PROVIDES THE BOOK OF
THE FEDERAL FUNDS TO COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES THROUGH FEDERAL
STUDENT AID'S PROGRAM H. B. C.
U. ALSO RECEIVES SMALLER AWARDS
FROM VARIOUS FEDERAL AGENCIES
INCLUDING. THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THE NATIONAL SCIENCE
FOUNDATION AND THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE H. B. C.
USE RECEIVE THIS DIRECT FUNDING
FOR OPERATIONS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE OF ITS HEAVY
CONTRIBUTION PROMOTING EQUAL AN
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND HELP
EQUITIES AT H. B. C. USE
DESIGNATION. WILL CORRECT A
DECADE OF PAST DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATE GOVERNMENT
I AM PROUD TO REPRESENT- TOLD
YOU TO MET SIGN- IN THE WHITE
COMMUNITY I WHERE I WAS BORN A
RACE WHERE I STAND ON THE
SHOULDERS OF THOSE WHO COME
BEFORE ME. IT IS A DIVERSE
INSTITUTION THAT ROLLS OUT OF
THE ASHES OF THE WATTS RIOTS TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF OUR COMMUNITY.
H. R. EIGHTY SIX SIX TWO
RIGHTFULLY RECOGNIZE THE H.
SKEWS ME I'VE TALKED CHARLES
UNIVERSITY MEDICINE SCIENCE- AS
AN H. B. C. U. BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT JOINING ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CHARLES
UNIVERSITY MEDICINE SCIENCE
MISTER DELUSION WHO WILL ALSO
TESTIFY. REGARDING H. R. EIGHTY
SIX. NECKAR RECOMMEND. MAKE A
MOTION I'LL SECOND THAT. THANK
YOU. MAYBE GET THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF MEMBERS OF THIS
DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE ON THANK
YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
FOR AUTHORING THIS MEASURE THEIR
LUCIEN HERE ARE REPRESENTATIVE
OF CHARLES R. DREW UNIVERSITY OF
MEDICINE AND SCIENCE I'M ALSO
JOINED I BELIEVE ON THE LINE BY
SYLVIA DREW IV WHO IS THE
YOUNGEST DAUGHTER OF DR CHARLES
DREW- WHO WILL BE PROVIDING SOME
BRIEF COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY AS WELL- CD WAS VERY
STORIED HISTORY EMANATING. FROM
THE WATTS REBELLION IT WAS AT
pIN OUR HISTORY AT LEAST WHERE
THERE WAS AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF
THE NEED TO BUILD INSTITUTIONS
THAT COULD SERVE A POPULATION
THAT HAD BEEN ECONOMICALLY
ISOLATED AND SUFFERED
SUBSTANTIALLY FROM HEALTH
DISPARITIES- THAT WAS THE BLACK
POPULATION OF THE WATTS
WILLOWBROOK AREA- AND THE NOTION
TO. SERVE THIS POPULATION BETTER
ONE OF THOSE COMPONENTS WAS
CHARLES R. DREW UNIVERSITY-
WE'VE SINCE GONE ON TO HAVE A
MUCH MORE- I'M NOT GONNA SAY
GLOBAL BUT A MUCH BROADER IMPACT
THAN JUST SIMPLY. OF THE
COMMUNITY OF WHAT'S IN
WILLOWBROOK ALTHOUGH WE DO
PROVIDE A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF
SERVICES IN THOSE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. ARAMBULA LEAVE THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WITH A FEW INTERESTING
STATS- AS TO WHY WE ARE SEEKING
THIS DESIGNATION AND THEN- WITH
THE PLEASURE BEACH CHAIR TO TURN
IT OVER TO- MISS CHU IV.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
BLACK POPULATION IN THE COUNTRY
PER THE US CENSUS. ARM YET WE
HAVE A HISTORICALLY BLACK
UNIVERSITY THAT DOES NOT HAVE H.
B. C. USE STATUS.ARE STILL
DIVERSITY OF FACULTY ADVERSITY
UNPARALLELED IN THE NATION- AND
IN THE STATE MAJORITY OF OUR
FACULTY ARE WOMEN 34% OF OUR
ROMAN IS BLACK 22% LATINO- IN
22% ARE ASIAN 66% OF OUR FACULTY
PEOPLE OF COLOR- WE HAVE
HISTORICALLY RECEIVED. FUNDING
FROM THE STATE OF THROUGH A
MEASURE SENATE BILL TEN TWENTY
SIX THAT WAS AUTHORED BY THEN
SENATOR MERVYN DONNELLY. ON WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW BY PRESIDENT
RONALD REAGAN. WHICH ESTABLISHED
A DEDICATED FUNDING STREAM FOR
THE UNIVERSITY THROUGH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA- THIS
ENTIRE SORT OF CONCEPTION OF THE
UNIVERSITY IN THE FUNDING
STREAM. STEM FROM A REPORT THAT
WAS COMMISSIONED IN THE
AFTERMATH. OF THE WATTS
REBELLION AND SO WE'RE WE'RE
THANKFUL I THINK TO BE HERE
TODAY WE'RE DOING SOME VERY
EXCITING THINGS ARE MEDICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM IS SLATED. TO
OPEN IN THE FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WANT THANK. MISTER
GIBSON FOR PERSONALLY
CHAMPIONING THIS IN IN THE BLACK
CAUCUS IS WELL FOR SUPPORTING
HIM WHEN THIS MEDICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM OPENS IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. WE'RE PROJECTED TO
INCREASE TOTAL BLACK MEDICAL
SCHOOL ENROLLMENT IN THE STATE
BY THIRTY PERCENT. ALL ONE
SCHOOL. AND TOTAL LATINO
ENROLLMENT IN THE STATE. BY
UPWARDS OF 20% ALSO WE'RE PROUD
OF THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. I'M ON THIS MEASURE-
AND- IF IT PLEASE THE CHAIR.
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A OUR OUR IN
HOUSE REPRESENTATIVE AT CHARLES
R. DREW UNIVERSITY SYLVIA. A JEW
IV MAKE SOME REMARKS. VERY GOOD
WHO WILL CALL ON THE SECOND
WITNESS. SHE'S ABLE TO BE AT T.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE THE SECOND
WITNESS. ON OUR LINE. EIGHTEEN
ANTI MATTER EITHER. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE WE LOOK AT THE
THANK YOU. SOME BUT IT WAS WHEN. THE SECOND NAME DOES NOT
APPEAR ON OUR AGENDA WHAT WHAT
WHAT'S THE NAME THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR SYLVIA DREW IV SHE
SHE MAY BE IN THE IN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT SECTION MR CHIA. OKAY-
SHOULD WE GO MOVE FORWARD AND
THEN AND THEN SEE WHEN WE GO TO
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS IF SHE'S
THERE YEAH WE'LL DO THAT ANY ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT HERE
IN THE- IN THE- BUILDING. CNN
WILL GO TO THE PUBLIC- Q. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
IN SUPPORT COM FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF HR EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN IT'S ONE TEN ZERO
ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR OUR FIRST
TIME.
CAN WE HAVE A FEW PEOPLE QUEUING
UP FOR COMMENT ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH MY NUMBER.
ALL.
HELLO GUYS ONE MORE MOMENT
PLEASE. I DON'T ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
SIXTY SIX MY NAME IS LINDA
CLEVELAND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE ORGANIZATION I WATCHED
CALL WAUCONDA AND I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS TO NAME A
TOSS TO UNIVERSITY AS THE H. B.
C. U. I THINK WITH THE
DESIGNATION. IT WOULD GIVE OUR
COMMUNITY OUR OUR KIDS WHO ARE
GOING OFF THE CLIFF EDGE- A
BETTER. BOB BOB WANT TO MAKE
THEM STAY HOME STAY AT HOME GO
TO SCHOOL AT HOME COME BACK WORK
IN THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE THESE
COLLEGES THEY ENCOURAGE
COMMUNITY ACTIVITY- COMMITTEE
ADVOCACY. AND BECAUSE- OKAY KIDS
WILL BE LOOKING MORE AT STANFORD
MACON CONTRIBUTING THEY'RE ON
COMMUNITIES I THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WITNESS LINE ONE ON.
LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY. THIS IS
ERIC WASHINGTON AND ADMIRED HIM
AS A POINT OF HR EIGHT SIX VERY
TARA BARBECUE GIPSON FOR MAKING
CHARGING UNIVERSITY. ALLEN HEAD
START BACKUP THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. ONE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS PATRICIA ANDERSON AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
DESIGNATING CHARLES UNIVERSITY
AT THE H. B. C. U. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. AND. ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX. AND AN EIGHTY FIFTY
ONE OUR REGION THANK. IN SUPPORT
IT WOULD BE WONDERFUL. THANK YOU
LINE ONE SEVENTY SIX. THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THEN WE WILL NOW GO TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF THEIR
ANY WITNESSES AND OP POSITION IN
THE HEARING ROOM. C. NINE-
MISTER MODERATOR WE COULD GO TO
THE PHONE LINES TO SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY WITNESSES- IN OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINES. COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO THE COMMAND AGAIN
ONE THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME OKAY DO WE
HAVE ANY TWEETERS IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THREE NINE- MISTER
MODERATOR IF WE COULD GO TO-
EIGHTEEN T. LINES FOR. ANY
WINNERS. ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
RELATING TO HR EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE THAN VERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU WE'LL GO NOW TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
DR WEBER. GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS- UP BY I ALWAYS
ENJOY SPEAKING ON- CHARLES DREW
AND ALSO H. B. C. USE I THINK
I'M NOT SURE I'M I'M MAY BE THE
ONLY ONE OR ONE A FEW HERE WHO
ACTUALLY I'M A GRADUATE OF AN H.
B. C. U. VERY PROUD GRADUATE OF
AN HBCU. I'M AND I'M ALSO VERY.
GRATEFUL FOR THE FOUNDING OF
TROLLS THROUGH MEDICAL SCHOOL
AND THE THINGS THAT IT HAS DONE
NOT ONLY FOR THE COMMUNITY BUT-
I'M I'M ALSO VERY FAMILIAR WITH
SOME OF THE PHYSICIANS THAT
HAVE- BONTA CHARLES DREW
UNIVERSITY. UNFORTUNATELY I
CANNOT SUPPORT THIS- AS A VERY
PROUD H. B. C. U. ALARM WE ARE-
WE KNOW THE PURPOSE OF H. B. C.
USE WE KNOW THE PURPOSE OF THE
FOUNDING WE ALSO KNOW THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE H. B. C. USE
HAVE HAD OVER THE HUNDRED PLUS
YEARS THAT THEY'VE BEEN THERE.
WITH BEING UNDER RESOURCE THAN
UNDERFUNDED- IN NOVEMBER OF
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE FIVE TITLE
THREE OF HIGHER EDUCATION ACT OF
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE. CONGRESS
OFFICIALLY DEFINED WHAT AN H. B.
C. U. AS- AN H. B. C. U. IS A
SCHOOL OF HIGHER LEARNING THAT
WAS ACCREDITED AND ESTABLISHED
ONE BEFORE NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR.
AND WHOSE PRINCIPAL MISSION WAS
THE EDUCATION OF BLACK AMERICANS
. UNFORTUNATELY CHARLES DREW
MEDICAL SCHOOL DOES NOT FIT INTO
EITHER ONE OF THOSE CATEGORIES.
CHARLES STREET WAS ESTABLISHED
IN AUGUST OF NINETEEN SIXTY SIX.
AND ITS SOLE MISSION WAS NOT THE
EDUCATION OF BLACK AMERICANS IT
WAS TO PROVIDE- A HEALTH
RESOURCE FOR AN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY WHICH WAS PART WHICH
WAS AND STILL IS POTENTIALLY
PREDOMINANTLY BLACK BUT UNLIKE
YOUR- HAIRY OUR MEDICAL SCHOOL
YEAR HOWARD MEDICAL SCHOOL
YOU'RE MORE HOUSE MEDICAL SCHOOL
WHOSE PRIMARY MISSION WAS TO.
SERVICE AND- PROVIDE EDUCATION
TO BLACK STUDENTS AT A TIME WHEN
WE COULD NOT GO TO OTHER
UNIVERSITIES- I'M CHARLES DREW
WAS NOT FOUNDED UNDER THOSE
PRINCIPLES AND IT WAS NOT
FOUNDED IN THE TIME FRAME THAT
WAS SPECIFICALLY DESIGNATED. YOU
KNOW SOME PEOPLE SAY WELL YOU'VE
GOT- YOU KNOW SAID THE
UNIVERSITY OF FREEPORT THAT WAS
GIVEN THAT H. B. C. U. DIED
DIAGNOSIS OR TITLE OR WHATEVER
AFTER NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR BUT
THAT WAS BECAUSE IT IS THE PART
OF THE SEVEN UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
IN SOUTHERN UNIVERSITY WAS
DEEMED. AN HBCU IN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY OR IT WAS ESTABLISHED IN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY. SO- YOU KNOW AS
A AS AN ALARM. I KNOW HOW WE
HAVE WORKED HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR H. B. C. USE. GET THE
PROPER FUNDING GET THE PROPER
RECOGNITION- WE GET HIT UP ALL
THE TIME BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
OFTENTIMES THE DIVISION ONE
SCHOOLS. BOB THAT PRODUCE A LOT
OF MONEY FOR TRADITIONAL
UNIVERSITIES. OUT WE OFTENTIMES
DON'T HAVE THE GENERATIONAL
WEALTH STREAM. OP FROM OTHER
UNIVERSITIES THAT HAVE FROM
THEIR ALARM- AND SO THIS MONEY
IS SPECIFICALLY RESERVED AND
THIS TITLE IS SPECIFICALLY
RESERVED. FOR A SPECIFIC SUBSET
OF UNIVERSITIES. AND BECAUSE
CHARLES TRUTH DOES NOT FIT INTO
THAT CATEGORY I CANNOT SUPPORT
IT TODAY- BUT I DO APPRECIATE.
THE DISCUSSION AND I APPRECIATE
ALL THAT STRUCTURE HAS DONE FOR
LOS ANGELES AND FOR. THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF OUR PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND CERTAINLY APPRECIATE- I'M DR
WEBER'S COMMENTS- SINCE I'VE
BEEN ELECTED- WE'VE BEEN DOING
SOME EXTRAORDINARY THINGS WE
STAND ON THE CUSP OF WANT ONE
THIS IS A RESOLUTION- AND THIS
RESOLUTION- WE HOPE IS
TRANSMITTED- TO MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TO INCLUDE- AS WELL AS
THE NATIONAL TRUST- TO INCLUDE
THE DESIGNATION AS WAS STATED BY
DOCTOR WEBER- THERE WAS IN FACT-
ONE WHO WAS BROUGHT IN AFTER THE
DATE THAT SHE HAD ARTICULATED- I
THINK WE STAND ON A TIME WE CAN
CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY AND CHANGE
HISTORY. ON CALIFORNIA HAS NO H.
B. C. U. CALIFORNIA HAS NO OTHER
JUST THAT NO OTHER INSTITUTION
LIKE CHARLES DREW WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY- BE A
TRENDSETTER WHEN IT COMES DOWN
TO SOLVE UNIVERSITY OF MEDICINE
SCIENCE AND ALSO IT'S NAMED
AFTER A PIONEER DR- ONE WHOSE
GREAT GODDAUGHTER WORKS- AT THE
INSTITUTION- IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. WHEN I WAS WAS ELECTED
TO THE UP TO FORTY THE NINETEEN
I WAS ABLE TO GET A SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
STATE'S BUDGET TO ASSIST CHARLES
UNIVERSITY IN TERMS OF- CONTINUE
TO BROADEN THEIR PERSPECTIVE- IN
LAST YEAR IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE- PRESENTED A CHECK FOR FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS SO THEY CAN
EXPAND THE CAMPUS WE STAND ON
THE CUSP OF MAKING CHARLES
UNIVERSITY- BIG SAVIOR OF THE
WEST COAST WHERE IT WAS ALREADY
ARTICULATED- BLACK AND BROWN I'M
STUDENTS IN THE WATTS COMMUNITY
ATTEND THERE THESE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES- TO THE WATTS
COMMUNITY IN THE GREATER
COMMUNITY OF LOS ANGELES. IT
STANDS DIRECTLY A HUNDRED YARDS
AWAY FROM MARTHA KING COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL WHERE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO GRADUATE FROM CHARLES
UNIVERSITY- MEDICINE SCIENCE GO
OVER DO THEIR RESIDENTS. AT MARK
CAN COME HIGH. AND SO THAT SETS
UP FOR SUCCESS IN THE END IN
ADDITION TO THAT DURING THIS
PANDEMIC THE EPICENTER WAS MY
COMMUNITY THE EPICENTER OF WHERE
COBIT NINETEEN IT WAS HIT- IT
WAS IN FACT MY COMMUNITY WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARM. OUR
COMMUNITY WITH THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST- THAT CAN GO TO THIS
INSTITUTION OF HIGHER LEARNING
AND BECOME THE MEDICAL EXPERTS
THAT THEY HAVE TRADITIONALLY
CONTINUE TO- GRADUATE- MOVING
FORWARD IF IN FACT ANOTHER-
PANDEMIC WESTIE HIT- CALIFORNIA.
I ABSOLUTELY WANT TO SAY. THAT I
AM DEEPLY CONCERNED ONE WHEN IT
COMES DOWN TO- THE COMMUNITIES
LIKE CHARLES LIKE- SKEWS ME THE
WATTS COMMUNITY AND ALSO
INSTITUTIONS LIKE CHARLES
UNIVERSITY MEDICAL AND SCIENCE
THAT CAN ABSOLUTELY BE THE
EXAMPLE- THE MODERN DAY EXAMPLE-
OF A SCHOOL THAT PROVIDES AND
WELCOMES- BLACK AND BROWN
STUDENTS TO GO INTO MEDICINE AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS INSTITUTION.
HAS CONTINUED TO DO I MISS
INTERNATIONAL SCHOOL IS VERY
DIVERSE- AND ICE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS BASED ON-
MY COMMENTS TODAY. THEY MISTER
GIBSON. AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING HIS RESOLUTION FOR. I
AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT IT I DO
HAVE ONE QUESTION THIS IS NOT
THE FIRST TIME. THE LEGISLATIVE
RESOLUTION. HAS SOUGHT TO URGE
THE DREW UNIVERSITY BE GRANTED-
H. B. C. USE STATUS BY THE
NATIONAL TRUST FOR HISTORIC
PRESERVATION. IS THERE ANYTHING
MORE THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN DO
THIS TIME TO ENSURE. A POSITIVE
RESULT. I THINK WE CALIFORNIA
GOING TO RECORD THIS RESOLUTION
I THINK IT SENDS A VERY CLEAR
MESSAGE THAT WE ARE MOTIVATED
AND ENTHUSIASTICALLY MOTIVATED
TO MAKING CHARLES UNIVERSE IN
MEDICINE AND SCIENCE HAVE THAT
DESIGNATION. AS H. B. C. U.
AGAIN IN CALIFORNIA AND WE WILL
BE IN FACT THE FIRST SO I THINK IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THAT I THINK OUR
VOICES WILL BE HEARD BY PASTORS
REV. TODAY AND ALSO ON THE FLOOR
THIS CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY.
DID YOU EVER MOTION OKAY IS THE
MOTIONED BY. ME DR CHOI CHOICE
AND A SECOND BY MR LEVINE THANKS
OF MADAM SECRETARY READ PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
BE ADOPTED AND GO TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR MEDINA HI MEDINA
HI CHILE. THANK CHOI I FONG.
FONG AYE BLOOM. GABRIEL IRWIN
IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE LOW LOW I
SANTIAGO. GALLAGHER BALLADARES I
WEBER WEBER NO. ONE PHILADELPHIA
SIX ONE THE BILL IS ON CALL. AND
NOW WE'LL GO TO ITEM FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX DR CHOI.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU THANK YOU
JAIL AND THE MEMBERS- I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT THE ASSEMBLY
BID- SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX- I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ARE ON THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS- THAT I IT WOULD BE
ACCEPTING TODAY. A. B. SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SIX IT IS AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE THAT WOULD TO. ENSURE
NINE CREDIT AND THAT THIS IS A
BOARD THE STUDENTS- WHO ARE
ATTENDING A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE HAVING V. EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE ESTRIN BODY ASSOCIATIONS AND
THAT HAVE THE ABILITY TO RUN FOR
STRATTON TRUSTEE. MANY STUDENTS
OUT WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE
NEEDS ARE ARE. PRETTY QUICK
COLLUDED FROM THE PARTICIPATING
IN THE STUDENT BODY ASSOCIATION
BECAUSE OF THE MINIMUM UNIT
REQUIREMENT THE NOTED THE IN THE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION COLD THE
SECTION. SEVEN SIX ZERO SIX ONE
A- DISCORD SECTION. INCLUDES
SUCH LANGUAGES STATING. IN COURT
BEFORE THIS EQUIVALENT FOR UNIT
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS A HAS ALLOW
SOME CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE ABILITY TO RAISE
THE UNIT AND THE GPA
REQUIREMENTS- TO AN I. IN
EXTEMPORE LEVEL THAT HAS A WOULD
USED TO ACCESS FOR STUDENTS OF
ALL BACKGROUNDS OF TO
PARTICIPATE THE INDUSTRY RUN BY
THE ASSOCIATION SO OR THE
ABILITY TO RUN FOR SHARON
TRUSTY. AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX
PROVISO DISABLED AND A NON
CREDIT STUDENTS AN ALTERNATIVE
METHOD OF LAW QUALIFYING FOR
CHILDREN GOVERNMENT- IN THE HOPE
THAT THAT THIS ENCOURAGES A
PARTICIPATION IN STRONG
GOVERNMENT FOR ALL TYPES OF
STUDENTS- BY REMOVING BARRIERS
AND BECOMING MORE INCLUSIVE I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE JASMINE-
BROUGH SAID THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF US CHILDREN SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
FOR BEING HERE TODAY IN ADDITION
TO KIMBERLY WHO WITH A JAM UP
COLLEGE AT THE TESTIFYING NO
REMOTELY IN SUPPORT ABA. AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX. THANK YOU
I WAS THE LAST MEANT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA AND HONORABLE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JASMINE PRASAD AND I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR THE STUDENT SENATE FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES MY
PURPOSE HERE TODAY IS TWO FOLD
IN FIRST TO RELAY HOW PROUD WE
ARE TO SPONSOR AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SIX AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI. AND SECOND
TO SHARE WITH YOU HOW IMMENSELY
IMPORTANT THIS BILL IS TO
COMMUNICATE WITH STUDENTS
PLAINLY THE KERR EDUCATION CODE
IS OUTDATED AND IT CREATES AN
EQUITIES FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICORP SYSTEM. DISABLED
STUDENTS UNDER SUBDIVISION B. OF
SECTION EIGHT FOUR EIGHT FIVE
ZERO AS WELL AS 240% OF ADULT
LEARNERS TO TAKE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION COURSES ARE
NOT BEING REPRESENTED WITHIN THE
STUDENT BODY ASSOCIATION. FOR
THOSE WHO MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
AWARE EARLIER THIS MONTH LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT OR L. A. CCD AND
REFUSED TO COMPLY WITH THE
AMERICAN DISABILITY ACT STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES PLEADED WITH
THE COLLEGE TO MAKE THEIR ONLINE
SERVICES ACCOMMODATE TO BLIND
STUDENTS BY ALLOWING SCREEN
READING SOFTWARE. LACC REFUSED
MAKE THESE ACCOMMODATIONS AND
PETITION TO THE SUPREME COURT
AND ALMOST PETITIONS THE SUPREME
COURT TO NOT ONLY WE CAN EIGHTY
EIGHT BUT ALSO TO LIMIT THE
VOICES OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ALREADY PARTICIPATE
IN FEWER EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES LIKE CLUBS OR ON
CAMPUS EVENTS COMPARED TO
NONDISABLED STUDENTS. ONE REASON
THAT THEY DO NOT PARTICIPATE IS
DUE TO LACK OF. INTERACTION WITH
THE CURRENT MINIMUM UNIT
REQUIREMENTS IT IS AN
INTENTIONALLY IT LEAVES OUT A
MAJORITY OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS FROM BEING MORE
INVOLVED ON CAMPUS. THE
LEGISLATURE MUST FIX THIS
OUTDATED EDUCATION CODE
REQUIREMENT TO PREVENT COLLEGES
LIKE ELLIE CCD FROM LIMITING
STUDENTS VOICES ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO ARE UNDER REPRESENTED. AS A
STUDENT WITH LEARNING
DISABILITIES I RESPECT AND- I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
FOR AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX
BECAUSE IN DOING SO. YOUR
ALLOWING EQUAL REPRESENTATION
ACROSS THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU JUST MEN AND THE KIMBERLY-
REMOTELY. ARE YOU CAN EVERYONE
HEAR ME YES. OKAY HUMBOLDT. GOOD
AFTERNOON ON A WHEELCHAIR MEDINA
AND MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY WILL AND I'M A JUNIOR
AT UC BERKELEY I ALSO SERVE AS A
JACK OF JACKLEY TO. GENERATION
OPPOSITE DELIGHT ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOR EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY REPRESENT OVER FOUR
THOUSAND STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND NATIONALLY WE ARE
PROUD BECAUSE FROM THE AB
SEVENTY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI.
WE IN CALL OF THE CALL
CALIFORNIA IS. TO BE FAIR UP
WITH INFLATION BUT INDIVIDUALS
AND IN IN BY IS A- BUT THE INTO
RESTRICTIONS. I THINK. A STAR IN
DISABILITY. BECAUSE MINIMUM YOU
ACROSS RIGHT NOTING CAL EDUCATE
CODE I. FROM WITH THE PLAN WHICH
- THE ALL. FROM BEING A PART IN
PART AT THE STATE AND ALLOW WITH
THE TRUCK BECAUSE THIS. WHICH IS
A VITAL IN AFTER I COULD WILL
CAMP QUALITY. THAT HAVE THE CALL
THE POWER TO DIRECTLY. EVEN
ASKING IF YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
ACT IN NINETEEN SEVENTY. THE END
OF THE WITH THE I ACT AND THIRTY
FIVE AND EMAIL WITH DISABILITIES
ACT AND NINETY. THERE'S STILL
MORE TO BE DONE DRUNKEN. TO
TRULY THIS MAN THE G. ROOTED
ABLE IF THEY'RE TIRED AND CUT-
PARKING SEVENTY THREE. WHEN
IMPORTANT OUT. FOR THE GROWTH
WILL THERE WAS. TO SPEAK FOR
HISTORICALLY COMMUNITIES THANK
CONSIST AND- ON. CAMPUS. WE ARE
PROUD TO COACH BY AND WILL
SUPPORT FOR AB TO THIRTY SIX IN
A- TO COULD NOT THAN AND HER. ON
ME BECAUSE CAMPUS AND SHOWING
BEEN THAT AND HER WHEN IT COMES. TO SHE CAN BE OF CHINA THE
STUDENT WILL BE THAT I.
ENCOURAGE I ON A BEACON THE THAT
. THANK YOU TO NUMBER CHOI WHEN
JUDITH IN THE CELL FOR THREE
SENATE. OF TALIBAN COMMITTEE
COLLEGES WHO. SOUND AND PUT YOUR
MAY. COMMITMENT TO A GLOBAL OF
COMPLETION THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY.
THANKS IN THE PORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THAT ZERO THE
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE NO
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE- HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE
OF MR MODERATOR COULD YOU SEE IF
THEY'RE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IN THE QUEUES.
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION A. B.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME
AND IF WE HAVE ANY TWEETERS IN
THE HEARING ROOM SEEN NONE. OF
THIS MODERATOR WE SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY WINNERS. ON THE PHONE. FOR
ADDITIONAL COMMENT RELATING TO
A. B. SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE OF THEM ZERO.
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE SEVEN
ZERO. AND MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE
NO COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THE- DOCTOR CHOI
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU I RESPECT TO BE AS FOR THE
EIFFEL THANK YOU DR CHOI. I WANT
TO THANK. DR CHOI FOR ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
FOR CHAMPIONING INCLUSIVITY.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY ONE POINT
SIX MILLION STUDENTS ATTENDING
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND IT IS IMPORTANT THAT EVERY
VOICE BE HEARD ADEQUATELY AND
RESENT REPRESENTATIVE IN THE
LEADERSIP SYSTEM. I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORT SUPPORTING
THIS BILL WHICH WOULD MAKE IT
EASIER FOR DISABLED AND NOT
CREDITED STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE
IN STUDENT GOVERNMENT WE HAD A
MOTION BY MISS BY A DENTIST AND
A SECOND BY MR LOW. MADAM
SECRETARY READ PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI HI CHOI
I FONG. FONG I BLOOM GABRIEL
IRWIN- IRWIN I KILEY LEVINE LOW
LOW I SANTIAGO VALLADARES
BALLADARES I WEBER WEBER I. THE
LITTLE BIT. SEVEN ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT AND WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AT THIS TIME I'M GOING
TO PASS THE GAVEL TO MISTER
LOWE. WELL I PRESENT MY BILL.
NOT THIS. ONE MISTER CHAIR THIS
IS ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN ZERO
ONE SECRETARY IS WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- TODAY PRESENT AB.
SEVENTEEN OH ONE. AB SEVENTEEN
OH ONE CREATES A FIVE YEAR
GRANT. TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM TO INCREASE
STUDENT ENROLLMENT AND BILINGUAL
AUTHORIZATION PROGRAM. THROUGH
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
FULL TIME FACULTY FOR BILINGUAL
AUTHORIZATION PROGRAMS THROUGH
ITS COLLEGES OF EDUCATION. THIS
WILL ESTABLISH A MECHANISM TO
SYSTEMATICALLY CHANGED THE
TRAJECTORY OF STUDENTS SERVED
WITHIN THE BILINGUAL
AUTHORIZATION PATHWAY BY
ENSURING THAT FACULTY ARE
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE INCREASED
COURSES IN THIS AREA THERE BY
ALLOWING STUDENTS TO MOVE
THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS MORE
QUICKLY WHILE ADDITIONALLY
ENABLING THESE PROGRAMS TO
SERVE. HIGHER NUMBERS OF
STUDENTS ENSURING THAT ENGLISH
LEARNERS IN BY LITERACY
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAMS IN
LANGUAGES SUCH AS SPANISH
VIETNAMESE CANTONESE MANDARIN
KOREAN AND ARABIC AND OTHER
LANGUAGES. WILL ADDRESS THE
LINGUISTIC EQUITY AND GLOBAL
ACHIEVEMENT ACROSS OUR STATE I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
SUGGESTED AND ANNOUNCES THAT
WILL CLARIFY CERTAIN ELEMENTS OF
THE BILL. FIRST IT TO GRANT IS
DESIGNED TO TARGET THE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
TENURED TENURE TRACK PER FULL
TIME LECTURER BILINGUAL FACULTY.
REFERENCES TO PART TIME AND
LIMITED TERM WILL BE REMOVED.
SECOND WAS SPECIFIED IT IS THE
INTENT OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
THE GRANT FUNDS MAY BE USED FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE PURPOSES UP 210%
AND BILINGUAL AUTHORIZATION
PROGRAM COORDINATORS RELEASE
TIME EQUITABLE IN AB TWO. POINT
TWO FULL TIME EQUIVALENT OR
THREE WAITED TEACHING UNITS PER
SEMESTER THIRD SPECIFY THAT A
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION AWARDED A
GRANT LET'S HAVE A FIRST YEAR TO
PLAN AND RECRUIT FACULTY. FOR
DELAYED BY YEAR FINAL REPORT TO
THE APPROPRIATE POLICY FISCAL
COMMUNITY OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
HERE WITH ME TODAY ON BEHALF OF
AB. SEVENTEEN OH ONE. IS DOCTOR
FATE CHEN PROFESSOR AND CHAIR
DEPARTMENT OF TEACHER EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY LONG
BEACH. AND JENNIFER BAKER NOW
MARTHA I'M SORRY MICHAEL MICHAEL
MASUTHA ON THE PHONE
SUPERINTENDENT OF ANAHEIM UNION
HIGH SCHOOL. ONE FROM THE REGION
PLEASE PRESENT WHENEVER READY
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
FASHION AND I'M TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION I AM BOTH THE
PROFESSOR AND THE CHAIR AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TEACHER EDUCATION
AT CAL STATE UNIVERSITY LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN-DEALING WITH THE SYSTEMIC
REDUCTION OF CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS WITH BINDING
AUTHORIZATIONS WHICH IS ONLY
MADE WORSE BY INCREASING TEACHER
SHORTAGE. THE CSU SYSTEM ISSUES
NEARLY 45% OF TEACHING
CREDENTIALS WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ENOUGH TO MEET
THE CURRENT AND FUTURE CSU
STUDENT NEEDS NOR THE NEEDS EVER
K. THROUGH TWELVE COUNTERPARTS
AB SEVENTEEN OH ONE WILL MOVE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD BY CREATING
MORE BILINGUAL FACULTY WHOWILL
BE ABLE TO OFFER MORE CLASSES
AND SUPPORT OUR CURRENT STUDENTS
WHO ARE FUTURE TEACHERS. I HAVE
BEEN PERSONALLY WORKING WITH
MANY CSU THE SINCE YOU
COLLEAGUES TO CREATE MORE ACCESS
FOR STUDENTS THROUGH A
CONSORTIUM FOCUSING ON ASIAN
LANGUAGES SUCH AS MANDARIN
CANTONESE KOREAN AND VIETNAMESE
WITHIN OUR EXISTING CSU NETWORK
OUR LIMITED SUPPLY OF FACULTY IN
THESE LANGUAGES HAS PREVENTED
STUDENTS FROM PARTICIPATING IN
BILINGUAL AUTHORIZATION PROGRAMS
WHICH ALSO MEANS WE ARE NOT
TRAINING OUR FUTURE TEACHERS TO
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE GROWING
POP GEN. OKAY IF YOU TRUST HIM
TO SPEAK ASIAN LANGUAGES AB
SEVENTEEN OH ONE IS TRULY A WIN
FOR THE CSU AND A WIN FOR
CALIFORNIA SIGNIFICANT
POPULATION OF ENGLISH LEARNERS
AND MULTILINGUAL LEARNERS I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF. SEVENTEEN OH
ONE AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH US UNDERSTAND THIS A SECOND
INDIVIDUAL WISHING TO TESTIFY AS
WELL ON THE PHONE LINE. PLEASE
PERCENT WHATEVER READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHAEL NOT STUDENTS CLAIMED THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE AND HIDING
IT IN HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
DISTRICT COMPRISED OF FIVE CITY. TWENTY NINE THOUSAND SEVEN TO
TWELVE STUDENTS. LAUGHTER
BILINGUAL TEACHERS WE SEE TODAY
HAVE BEEN PARTLY DUE THE ENGLISH
FOR THE CHILDREN ERA.CAN A
RIPPLE EFFECT FROM TWO TWO SEVEN
WHICH IS UNDERMINE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BUILD CAPACITY
WITH OUR- YES YOU COLLEAGUES TO
SUPPORT MULTILINGUALISM. THERE
ARE MANY STEPS INCLUDING THAT WE
CAN DO THAT. DEAL WITH THIS
PROBLEM INCLUDING AB SEVENTEEN
OH ONE SPONSORED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. UPDATE IN MY
DISTRICTS WHERE THEY WORK SO.
NATIVE LANGUAGES. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE THE TRIBULATION FROM
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT
TWENTY TWO BILINGUAL PEOPLE
MERGING PROGRAMS AND SPANISH AND
KOREAN WE NEED BILINGUAL
TEACHERS AND CONTENT AREAS TO
CONTINUE THE INCREDIBLE WORK OF
OUR ELEMENTARY SCHOOL PARTNERS.
ARE DISTRICT CURRENTLY PROVIDES
INTERNSHIPS AND WITH OVER NINETY
THAT THE NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS IN OUR STUDENTS
BILINGUAL SKILLS ARE HIGHLY
VALUED. KAISER PERMANENTE ACHE
AND DISNEY AMONG MANY MANY
OTHERS HELLO- REALLY- COMMENTED
THAT OUR KIDS COMING OUT WITH BY
LEGAL CAPACITY OF THE TEACHING
TO CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. IT IS
INCREDIBLE INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
TO FIND AND RETAIN BILINGUAL
AUTHORIZED TEACHERS IT IS
SPECIALLY CONCERNING TO HAVE A
BILINGUAL TEACHER SHORTAGE AS WE
NOT ONLY TRY TO SEARCH BY
ENGLISH LEARNERS BUT ALSO OUR
STUDENTS. COME FROM ENGLISH ONLY
HOUSEHOLDS THAT SEE THE BENEFIT
OF BILINGUAL EDUCATION. I KNOW
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES TO
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE. THAT
ARE LOOKING TO THEIR LOCAL
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS TO
GROW THE PIPELINE FOR BILINGUAL
TEACHERS AND BILINGUAL
AUTHORIZATION PROGRAMS NEED THE
SUPPORT. OF THIS LEGISLATION TO
INCREASE THEIR CAPACITY TO FILL
OUR NEED. SCALING UP BY LEGALLY
AUTHORIZED TEACHERS NEEDED TO
HAPPEN YESTERDAY SO THIS IS THE
NECESSARY STEPS TO HELP REBUILD
CAPACITY AND AS WE ENTER OUT OF
HIS HAND DOWN AGAIN TO THE
ENDEMIC PHASE ONE THING THAT.
CALLED IT HAS TAUGHT. ME THAT
THE WORLD IS MORE GLOBALLY INTER
. THAN EVER BEFORE AND IT'S
REALLY INCUMBENT UPON ALL OF US
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIANS CAN
CONTINUE TO LEAD IN THIS
GLOBALLY INTERCONNECTED. WORLD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK VERY
MUCH FOR TO. IT TO THE MODERATE
EITHER A NEED TO WITNESSES
MISSION IS IN SOME ON THIS BILL
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN THE- OF AB
SEVENTEEN OH. PLEASE PRESS. THEN
ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE
ZERO. THE FIRST WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE THANK YOUNG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES AND UNION
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE TEAM
THAT I NEED IS NOT TO NOT ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
. IN THE LIGHT OF ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS SHARON MERIT. I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
TEACHER AT HM CALLING ANSWER
DRAWN SUPPORT AT THIS BILL. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THAT TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR MODERATOR NOW CALLING UP ALL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM AT THIS TIME OUR EDITING
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THIS
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM AT THIS
TIME WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. C. NINE WILL TURN
BACK TO THE MODERATOR MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
. FOUR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO
A. B. SEVENTEEN OH ONE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. TAX
MANAGER AND ONE OF THEM ZERO. SH
SH SH. SH AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT
COMING THROUGH AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR.
MODERATOR AND FOLLOWING THE
TRADITION OF. COMMITTEE CHAIR
WE'RE GOING TO ASK ARE THERE ANY
TWEETERS CURRENTLY HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM AT THIS
TIME WISHING TO SPEAK. C. NONE
EIGHTEEN TWO MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY TRAINERS ON THE PHONE AND IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. FOR
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS RELATING TO
EIGHT B. SEVENTEEN OH ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE OF THEM ZERO. COMMENT
AGAIN ONE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THAT CONCLUDES THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AT THIS TIME NOW WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME OR MOTION. ZAVENTEM
MOTION. S. SECOND BY A DOCTORWEBER AND THEN WE'LL GO TO A
DOCTOR WEBER FOR. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU CHAIR I'M-
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I'M I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE START FOCUSING
NOT ONLY ON MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE BILINGUAL EDUCATION FOR
THOSE WHO- HAVE ENGLISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE BUT MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE ALSO ARMING ARE.
PARTY YOUTHS WHO HAVE ENGLISH AS
A PRIMARY LANGUAGE AT HOME THE
ABILITY TO COME BY OR
TRILINGUAL- I DID WANT TO POINT
ONE THING OUT THOUGH- WHEN I
LOOKED AT THE BILINGUAL
AUTHORIZATION. COURSES OR OR
LANGUAGES THAT WERE OFFERED AT
CSU WE HAVE ERA BACK- ARMENIAN
CANTONESE AMONG JAPANESE COMER
KARAN MANDARIN PORTUGUESE
PUNJABI SPANISH FILIPINO AND
VIETNAMESE. CALIFORNIA IS A VERY
VERY DIVERSE STATE- AND I KNOW
WE HAVE A- ALSO A LARGE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO COME FROM AFRICAN
COUNTRIES THAT SPEAK. DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES THEY SPEAK SWAHILI
THEY SPEAK I'M HARDLY SPEAK
FRENCH- WE HAVE A LARGE FAMILY
POPULATION- AND- IN MY DISTRICT
AND UP AND DOWN THE STATE AND
SO. I WOULD HOPE THAT- AS WERE
LOOKING TO GET MORE FUNDS THAT
WE START TO EXPAND. THE NUMBER
OF- BILINGUAL AUTHORIZATION
COURSES THAT WE HAVE ICS USED TO
BE MORE INCLUSIVE. OF ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK VERY
MUCH TALKED ABOUT AND ADDITIONAL
THE COMMENTS AT THIS TIME HAS
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND OF.
THE CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
AUTHOR FOR ANY CLOSING REMARKS
THANK YOU FIRST. I'D LIKE TO
CLARIFY THAT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
I ENUMERATED AYE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE WILL BE TAKING BUT ARE NOT
ACTUALLY TAKING AND THAT THIS
COMMITTEE BUT WILL BE TAKEN AS
THE BILL MOVES FOR. OUT THANK
YOU DR WEBER FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
THIS MORNING. AS I TOURED MY
GRANDDAUGHTERS FOURTH GRADE
CLASS ON THE FLOOR OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND WAS TAKING THEM OUT
TO TAKE THE PICTURES ON THE WEST
STEPS. A GROUP OF FRENCH
SPEAKING STUDENTS WALKED INTO
THE BUILDING ALL SPEAKING FRENCH
AND I THOUGHT WILL ARE THEY
VISITING HERE FROM FRANCE AND
THEY WERE NOT. THEY WERE FROM A
FOR I DON'T KNOW WHERE OF FRENCH
SPEAKING SCHOOL SOMEWHERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO I THINK
DOCTOR WEBER THAT YOUR COMMENT
IS WELL TAKEN AND I WOULD PASS
THAT ON TO THE FOLKS. AT CSU.
FIFTY YEARS AGO ALMOST FIFTY
YEARS AGO. I GRADUATED FROM-
STUDENT TEACHING. AT UC
RIVERSIDE WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
BILINGUAL BICULTURAL. EDUCATION
AND I BEGAN. TEACHING IN A
BILINGUAL. SPANISH ENGLISH
CLASSROOM. IN RIVERSIDE. AND
THAT CAME AFTER THE DECISION OF
LAOS. THE LAO DECISION WHICH
SAID THAT CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
AND I THINK STUDENTS. ACROSS THE
NATION WE'RE NOT TRULY EDUCATED
IF THEY WERE NOT EDUCATED IN
THEIR OWN LNGUAGE AND I BELIEVE
THAT WAS A- DECISION THAT CAME
OUT OF SAN FRANCISCO. SO I AM
PROUD TO BE A BILINGUAL TEACHER
AND VERY HAPPY TO BE THE AUTHOR
OF AB SEVENTEEN OH ONE. I THINK
THAT YOUR COMMENTS HERE ARE ARE
VERY WELL TAKEN THAT IS NOT ONLY
FOR NON. ENGLISH STUDENTS BUT
BUT MANY OF OUR STUDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WANT TO. BE
BILINGUAL OR SOMETIMES EVEN
SPEAK THREE LANGUAGES SO WITH
THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON A B. SEVENTEEN AWAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND IN
THE MOTION BEFORE US IS TO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTIONS TO
PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEDINA HI. MEDINA I
CHOI FONG FONG I BLOOM GABRIEL
IRWIN- WHEN I KILEY. KILEY NOT
BOATING LEVINE LOW AYE LOW AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I VALLADARES
CALAVERAS I WEBER. WEBER I.
LEVINE I. EIGHT ZERO OUT THE
BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES THE BILL'S
HOUSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR. MEASURE WILL MOVE ON TO
THE FINAL ITEM FOR THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY. THAT IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN TWELVE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE. MISTER
CHAIR PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER READY THANK YOU
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTEEN TWELVE. AB SEVENTEEN
TWELVE WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
TO CONDUCT A SURVEY PERTAINING
TO CAMPUS CLIMATE AND SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT. REPORTS OF RACIALLY
TARGETED VIOLENCE AGAINST API
MUSLIM BLACK AND OTHER STUDENTS
OF COLOR ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
HAVE RISEN BY ALMOST 57% OVER
THE LAST DECADE. ACCORDING TO
THE GROUP RAPE ABUSE AND INCEST
NATIONAL NETWORK 13% OF ALL
STUDENTS EXPERIENCE RAPE OR
SEXUAL ASSAULT THROUGH PHYSICAL
FORCE. VIOLENCE OR IN CAPS
INCAPACITATION. FIVE POINT 8% OF
STUDENTS HAVE EXPERIENCED
STALKING SINCE ENTERING COLLEGE
. TWENTY THREE POINT ONE OF
TRANSGENDER GENDERQUEER
NONCONFORMING COLLEGE STUDENTS
HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
COLLEAGUES FOR THESE REASONS A.
B. SEVENTEEN TWELVE IS A MUCH
NEEDED STEP FOR CAMPUS CLIMATE
OVERSIGHT THIS BILL WILL DEVELOP
A CAMPUS CLIMATE AND SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT SURVEY WHICH WILL BE
ADMINISTERED TO STUDENTS EVERY
THREE YEARS AND REPORT THE
RESULTS TO THE GOVERNING BOARD
OF EACH INSTITUTION. AB
SEVENTEEN TWELVE WILL ALSO
PROMOTE AWARENESS AND HELP
DEVELOP SAFETY PROTOCOLS FOR
TARGETED STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF KIMBERLY WILL A
STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY. AND
DIRECTOR OF CHEN UP. AND MADISON
CAMPBELL C. E. O. OF LEADER HELP. I THINK BOTH ARE ON THE PHONE
LINES I BELIEVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BUT NOW THEY GO ON TO OUR
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
WE CAN WITH. A MISS KIMBERLY
WILL PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHATEVER READY. CAN EVERYONE
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN THANK YOU.
HEY SAM OKAY YEAH MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY WILL AND I'M
UNDERGRADUATE JUNIOR AT UC
BERKELEY AND I SERVE AS THE
JUDGE OF JACKLEY TO GENERATION
UPDATED EDUCATION ACT AT THE
LIMITATIONS THAT REPRESENTS OVER
FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE IS EXPANDING
NATIONALLY. OTHER PROBLEMS
BECAUSE SPONSORED GAMBLING
COINSURANCE INCLUDING YOUR
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
TWELVE THANK CHAIR MEDINA WHICH
WOULD REQUIRE ENCOURAGE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS EACH GENERATE A QUOTE
PRETENDING TO CAMPUS. CLIMATE
AND SEXUAL MISCONDUCT. WE ARE
DONE UP WHAT TO FEEL SAFE
WELCOMED IN NIGER WITH THE CHAU
. OF DISCRIMINATION AS AN ASIAN
MALE ENDED I KERRY EMOTIONAL
THANK BLOW WHEN HEARING THE
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE COULD
INCREASE. OF OVER NINE THOUSAND
HATE CRIMES AGAINST API
COMMUNITIES. THE RACIAL
POLITICIZATION OF THE PANDEMIC.
DISCRIMINATION CHOM BECAUSE
PEOPLE OF COLOR LIKE ME EVERY
DAY. FUND HOPE FOR ACTS OF HATE
SPEECH TO VIOLENT HATE CRIMES
WHICH FACTORED INTO APPROACH OF
RACIALLY TARGETED VIOLENCE
AGAINST ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS
MONTH ONE BLOCK AND OTHER
STUDENTS OF COLOR ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES THAT ALREADY RISEN BY.
ALMOST. 57% OVER THE LAST
DECADE. I STILL BE GREAT CRUCIAL
AWARENESS TO THE HIGH CENTRAL
VALLEY AND SUCH PASSED INCIDENT
. OF AUTO DESTRUCTING BY MAY
WELL MY- FACE TIME THE A CONDO
HOME LOAN AT NIGHT AND FEEL TAX
ANY AND WITH THE- OF. CAN THE
PERCENT ALL. EXPERIENCE WAS
ASSAULT THE PHYSICAL. BALLOT OR
INCAPACITATION. STUDENTS DATA
FROM THESE REPORTS AB SEVENTEEN
TWELVE WILL PROVIDE CAMPUSES
WITH THE NECESSARY INFORMATION
TO TRULY UNDERSTAND AND ADDRESS
THE COURT CULTURAL. WORKING TO
COMBAT IDENTITY BASED
DISCRIMINATION AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE ON CAMPUS. THEREFORE
JOHN ARE THE POPULAR SPONSORS
INCLUDED YOUR SUPPORT AND
PASSAGE OF AB SEVENTEEN TWELVE
CAN SHOW OFTEN LIVE IN THE
SPACE. ENVIRONMENT WE LASSEN
INFORMATION SO THEY CAN FEEL
POWERED AND WELCOMED BY THE
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU. SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR NOW ON.
MATT CAMPBELL. I'VE NEVER HEAR
ME YES WE CAN PLEASE PRESENT
WHATEVER READY. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS NANCY CAMPBELL AND I'M THE
FOUNDER AND NEED HELP I AM PROUD
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN TWELVE THE DAY BEFORE
I BEGAN I KNOW THERE ARE MANY
SURVIVORS THANK YOU BYE AND I
WANT TO START OFF BY PHONE. VIA
AND THERE ARE RESEARCH IN
SUPPORT AVAILABLE FOR YOU HELP
YOU NAVIGATE THE CHALLENGES
YOU'RE FACING. THE HOUSE LOOKS
DOWN IN TWENTY NINETEEN PREPARE
VIBRATE AND BY PROVIDE REFLECTS
WITHOUT I MYSELF AM IN SURVIVOR
I WAS ACTUALLY FOUNDED BACK IN
COLLEGE LIKE 13% OF STUDENTS
NATIONWIDE AND LIKE THE MAJORITY
OF SURVIVORS. I DID NOT GO TO A
HOSPITAL OR TO THE PLATE AND BAD
I GREW UP THE TV ADS PICKED UP A
BOTTLE OF JET BLACK HAIR DYE AND
TRY TO GET. IT WOULDN'T INCLUDE
ME TOO MOVEMENT PICKED UP
MOMENTUM THEY. REALIZED THEY
WENT AROUND. WE'VE ALL HEARD
STORIES ABUSE THE FACT MAY BE
MORE INSIDE. ONLY BECAUSE- CHIU
TIMES LIKELY BE ABOUT THE DENVER
. LGBT I A STUDENT CASE GRAY
GRANT. 23% OF TRANS. NINETEEN
COLLEGE PLEASE THE ME TO. AND
THE CAR. DOWN BIG OR WITH TRUMP
AND- WE FEEL FIRST WITH OUR AND
CAN BUT- HE DIDN'T HAVE TOWARD
THE- GRADE COULD. OUT ABOUT
MONEY WITH YOUR- THERE EVEN FOR.
OUT AND ON CAMPUS SEVEN TWO
POINT EIGHT PER OF PROVIDE. WORK
FOR MENTAL COMPLICATION. AND
DESPITE EARNING A HIRED. 85% OF
THOSE ARE. THAN FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS. GRADUATION
THESE ARE THE CARDS. AFFECTS
ASSAULT. BUT I. LEVEL TICKETS
THEIR- OF. ISOLATION DEPRESSION
INVITING SURVIVORS ARE TRYING
MORE. TO ATTEMPTING. AND ABOUT
THE- TO PTSD. THE REAL CALM. OF
THE- ARE ARMED CARE FOR DIVIDE
WITHOUT. AND PUT ME WANT IT. IF
THE CAR. FOR CHIU SCARED HAVING
. BUT AB DE. TWELVE WEEK
TEACHING BACK. I STRONGLY. AB
TWO BECAUSE IT CENTRAL WITH. THE
VOICE OF VIPER IN THE DO TO. ON
OUR- MEEDER WE NEED A- WITH
CAMPUS ARE. WE START BY NAMES AB
. PROPER UNIVERSITY. UNITS BY
MEN. CAMPUS INTERFACE FINE. AND
WORKING GROUP'S TRACK PATCHWORK.
YOU OUT OF YOUR SUPPORT IN THE
MEASURE TO DATE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT CONCLUDES THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR PRIMARY
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINES ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE COMMUNITY
ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME. PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE AND
JUST SIMPLY STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. FOR THE RECORD.
WELCOME I'VE GOT A FUTURE
MEMBERS- ANY SOCCER I WOULDN'T
WITH THE STUDENT CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
HIGH SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HEARING THE COMMITTEE
ROOMS. CNN WILL MOVE ON TO THE
MODERATOR. A. T. MODERATE WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME OF ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN TWELVE. HE MEDICARE
FOR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTEEN TWELVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN OF ONE SEVEN ZERO. FOR THE
FIRST BILL ABOUT THE LINE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO. STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT
COMING THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHEN I MOVE
ONTO WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM AT THIS TIME. CNN WILL MOVE
ON TO THE MODERATOR MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. OR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION. AB
SEVENTEEN TWELVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE IF AND ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THEN A MOVE. TO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS ALREADY ENJOYS A
MOTION AND A SECOND AND A
DIFFERENT QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME SEE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SECURITY WAS TO CLOSE
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I
JUST WANNA BE CLEAR THAT I WILL
BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS TODAY TO ALLEVIATE
CONCERNS REGARDING THE WORKGROUP
. THIS WILL ELIMINATE THE
WORKGROUP AND ENABLE EACH
COVERING OFFICE FOR EACH SEGMENT
TO CREATE A SURVEY FOR THEIR OWN
INDIVIDUAL SYSTEM. IT WILL ALSO
ALLOW THE INDIVIDUAL SEGMENTS TO
INCORPORATE THIS SURVEY INTO AN
EXISTING SURVEY TO REDUCE SURVEY
FATIGUE. AMONG STUDENTS I'M ALSO
AWARE THAT THERE IS A FEDERAL
BILL WHICH REQUIRES ALL POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
TO CONDUCT A SURVEY EVERY TWO
YEARS AND I PLAN TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS IN APPROPRIATIONS. TO
INCORPORATE THE FEDERAL LANGUAGE
OF THIS THESE AMENDMENTS WAS
STRENGTHENED THE BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I BOOKED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR FROTHING THE
BILL IN ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AT THIS TIME THIS
MOTION BEFORE US IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI. MEDINA HI CHOI. FONG FONG I
BLOOM. GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN I KILEY. KILEY I. LEVINE
LEVINE I LOW AYE LOW AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I KNOW THERE
IS NO THERE IS I WEBER. WEBER HI. IN TEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
OR ANYTHING. WILL MOVE TO A
ADELINE STARTING WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. K. A. CONSENT
CALENDAR BLOOM GABRIEL GABRIEL I
KILEY KILEY I. ELEVEN ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT. THE
ITEM ONE AB SIXTEEN OH TWO.
BLOOM GABRIEL GABRIEL I KILEY
KILEY I. ELEVEN ZERO AB SIXTEEN
OH TWO IS OUT. ITEM TWO AB
SEVENTEEN OH ONE. CHOI BLOOM
GABRIEL GABRIEL HI. FROM. NINE
ZERO AB SEVENTEEN OH ONE IS OUT
. ITEM THREE AB SEVENTEEN TWELVE
CHARLIE BLOOM. TEN ZERO A. B.
SEVENTEEN TWELVE IS OUT. ITEM
FIVE AB. SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX
BLOOM GABRIEL GABRIEL I KILEY
KILEY I. LEVINE LEVINE HI
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI.
ELEVENS.
I LEVINE. LEVINE I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI. KILEY BELT CHANGE I
TO NOT VOTING.
WE HAVE NOT YES OKAY. NINE ONE
HR EIGHTY SIX IS OUT. I DON'T
THINK HE'S COMING BACK. DON'T
YOU THINK OF I'VE BEEN. ALL
RIGHT. THAT INCLUDES ALL THE
BILL'S GOING TO EXTEND MY
GRATITUDE TO THE EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE
STAFF THE RULES COMMITTEE STAFF
THE LEGISLATIVE DATA CENTER AND
ALL TO INSURE THAT THIS HEARING
COULD TAKE PLACE WITH THAT THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. IS A DIRECT.